She starts singing actually, because I've got a minute to myself without any singing.
Well, then try to get Amy's music video made.
Well, I'm just checking the last freaking donation, like the tip that's registered on stream
elements.
Anonymous says, after donating all the money I have to you girls, I'll be bankrupt but
it'll be worth it to see you all smile.
No anon, that's not how it works, bend over, BUNK, BUNK, BUNK.
Good morning, good evening, good afternoon.
In the month of August, that's right, we're streamed, so now it's my favourite kind of thing.
And yes, it's four o'clock in the morning for me, I'm in Australia.
I've got my thumb open.
That's right, right, hold on, let me pin, I need to pin it.
So I'm collabing with an ace marker called Yui, she's the one that was like, oh it doesn't
take the wheel.
I told her, the reeflings and I are going to be working together on the script together.
She's like, I trust you and the reeflings, I trust you, are the reeflings to be trusted?
No, no, I like being a control freak.
She's like, I feel bad you're doing all the work.
I'm like, no, no, I like being a control freak with it because it makes it so much easier.
I'm just giving away all the secrets.
Reeflings are to be trusted with my life.
I love them.
Just to reassure.
A hell no, what are you to trust?
Wait, Stronny's on the train?
Hell yeah, I'm on the train.
Right, I first open up YouTube, geez, I'm having a stroke.
I don't think I can, well, there's a good time to shoot.
I'm going to say that people forgot that.
Also, thank you to everyone who's been clipping me.
I sent away like seven clips to be made yesterday with another editor.
Arissa's still going to be my main editor, but...
I don't know how are you, I'm good, I got six hours of sleep.
Someone commented on my newest short and it's just my hips and they're called a gossling.
That's so cute.
It's just my, but it's like my bikini hips, you know what I'm saying?
Sorry, I'm just approving all of the wee comments that I got.
I'll approve the comments after stream, sorry I'm getting distracted.
But we have a whole day we get to spend together.
I'm so fucking hate.
I love stream sniping.
I love playing with the replays.
I don't know how other people can fucking hold them back.
I get feral.
I'm like, yes, yes, connect to my IP.
Let me see your location.
Anyway, I'm just a wee bit, a wee bit happy that we're playing again.
Okay, I am called Shtironi Snipes.
This is the steam account.
That little question.
Oh wait, I didn't even put anything with that.
Hold on.
Theme account to add to join.
And then it's the mommy wants to dox me.
No, well, if I want to dox you to myself so I can come and...
Plop, plop, plop, plop, plop.
That's right.
Get vermin tight.
That's not how that works.
Okay, there you go.
I do have me piece of paper to write down all of your adorable name.
Checkmate you.
Have we joined last time?
Should we hold off?
No.
So this is a clean slate.
Today is a clean slate.
It does not matter if you were in the first lobby, the last lobby, the Elemino P lobby,
the HIJK Elemino here.
When it's a new day, it's a new stream sniping.
It doesn't matter what time you came in.
I will acknowledge it's not the weekend.
We, we, we will do stream sniping days on week, days because, because, because, because...
Oh, God.
I forgot how to add.
Oh, scroll down bitch.
Scroll down.
We will do it.
But I will aim for the majority of the...
Oh, God, how did I...
Wait, why can't I hear any game sound?
Is it me?
Am I the problem?
Wait, start game.
Play reverses again.
Huh?
Is this right?
Or have I fucked up?
I don't remember the cinematic.
Am I gone mad?
You can...
Is she men?
Oh, oh my God.
She's men.
Oh, men.
Get that woman some lithium.
Is she dead?
Sorry, I don't remember seeing the cinematic.
You're, you're being forced to watch it with me.
I do not recall.
The necromancer is her twin sister.
Oh.
Oh?
Harry Potter.
The boy who left.
Come to die.
Is that why she always gets so close to death when she...
Oh.
Oh, is advertising the DLC to me?
Wait, no.
Did I just get advertised to be a cinematic?
Did I just fall for advertising?
I can't believe it.
I just fell for fucking advertising.
What's this?
Ranged headshots?
No.
Aura that reduces damage.
Marcus charges forward, you know.
I like, I like playing the default.
Sorry, I like him.
You just advertised to all of us.
I'm so sorry.
I fell for it.
I'm sorry.
Look at her.
I suck.
Now, there isn't ooh, ooh.
I'm rolling.
I'm breaking free.
74.
Get every default.
Yeah, I find him just the easiest to play.
How do I change my answer to it?
Oh.
Doesn't play game for one week.
Instantly forgets how to do anything.
Like, instantly I want to do a claim.
I don't know what I'm claiming.
Five shillings.
I'm not going to be on it.
I like, they kind of outdid those like, I don't know,
70 years ago or something in the UK.
Maybe even longer.
A shilling.
How do I change my mode out?
Is it hero selection?
No.
Inventory.
Yeah, okay.
Wait, that one's...
Why is it...
Heroic assisting an ally under attack resource 15 temporary health
from both players?
That's like...
Wait, so if a...
Oh god, I got an achievement.
Equipped an exotic item.
What makes it so exotic?
I don't know how that would make it exotic, but sure, sure.
Hmm, hmm, hmm, hmm.
Hmm, hmm, hmm.
Hi, we're friends.
Let me write down your names.
Okay, in today's Agenda Nation.
Are we doing team names, so?
I don't know if we're still doing team names.
Okay.
Red and red are...
Red, red and red are...
with you single and on you which my eyes really can't read that well for some
reason I can hardly read your name yeah do team name okay let's take a look oh
we've got over Bowen we're bowing he said yes respect charm we've got
Kimberly and then we got the neck cool well no not the neck cool because we
were advertised to I need to drink my tea before the Bowers well just do that
because you guys are kneeling the kneelers Bowers that sounds terrible
bower you bow bow or now bow curtain call okay curtain close curtain you can
kind of see my thought curtain close bow kneel type thing I kneel my knees are
through the floor type name I'm so sorry this is rubbish oh that's a good
combination name the omni scene crusades yeah that works okay I've
right down that one as well the omni scene crusades that's such a good
combination combination I like the combination yo a vtuber playing
vermin toad yeah you can even stream snip if you like and I don't get it but
I'm just happy to be here right okay so we last time we played we played all of
Helmgar we did everything even the shitter gate now there's only a bing bang
boom there's only three of these and then there's DLC but we're not we're not
buying them because I fucking can't stand that shit so instead we're gonna
play these and try our best but whether or not oh sorry my throat farted if you
heard that we're just gonna try our best to see what happens and DLC hate just
literally just put it in the fucking base game
let's put it in the base game
put it in the base game
legendary difficulty exactly is it loud enough or do I need to make it louder
oh my god this place actually doesn't look like it's been decimated and people
are able to live here louder got it
to right here we go testing testing okay this place looks nice and not
absolutely destroyed by the rats the most legendary difficulty of all time
I was picking my lip yesterday and I split it open really badly it was
bleeding for ages is it still too quiet
still a quiz
wait out to me am I getting roasted in game and I'm blabbing over it
yeah all right what I need to do oh these are orcs oh my gosh it's the
refling farm it's the refling farm get out of her farm we're taking it back
over it belongs to us get out of here get out of here you're stealing your
bountiful harvest for the year leave us be fellow beasts the food is for gammy
and her family only that can scavenge this is our bountiful that's what I
think about you ruining my farm there's something green over there there's
something green happening I'm not going I mean sorry about your lip oh you see
that aim but oh yeah he was going for my refland all of a sudden I can aim when
it goes when the enemy goes for my refland I think we might do a karaoke
soon but I'm dictating my terrible songs okay you're we'll have to tolerate
oh I didn't realize they can jump fences I was just in straight form a
a what's that I'm just casually cornering myself in what no what are you
talking about I'm being dumb but I'm not I'll need to rate the karaoke list but
it's gonna be all the songs that I know because if I know the song I go
absolutely eat shit I'm like if I don't know the song feel really bad because
I'm just like muttering through the lyrics because I don't know like the
temple of the song or anything
and yes save that refund did you see that in 4k and yeah they're not mumbling
too much if I don't know the song otherwise is it they're here hey excuse me
mr. gay I hear chickens we have chickens on the farm we're so good so about four
songs you know one how do you speak so confidently and so loud to you met oh no
I'm sorry I didn't mean to do it oh are we ready
I think we have I try I'm spraying I don't know I can't see hold on I'm itching
my face and yes and but I don't really have much exciting news I think you're
blowing ASMR so I was being dumb as I always am I was like oh I need all nine
audios to go up on patron at the exact same time I don't know why I do that to
myself that's not how it works so there's gonna be an ear blowing ASMR it's
literally no talking ear blowing and it's not looked like it's actually like I
sat and recorded it because some people I don't like looped ASMR honestly I
completely get that so I literally sat for 20 minutes blowing in the ears to
the microphone like and so that's gonna be my next milestone upload there are
some that have talking there's some that don't have talking but like I need to
stop being so harsh on myself and so tomorrow so after stream there'll be a
patreon early access upload but you don't it's not like you're missing it so
don't feel forced to like give you know they'll be forced to like by the
server gammies having a face are you hungry gammies no come back I feed you
gammies eating a cheese slice what what a distinguished gentle girl a source
that's going to a literal rage of anger I hate it wow you have come to the wrong
streamer my entire life is ASMR unironically Recon you need to heal
them oh my gosh is that a Roman soldier it's a Roman soldier rat when I still
haven't confirmed it oh darn it won't stop me from seeing the cuttlefish
though I always come back oh you're literally I was about to say that's
literally what I like a fan-off moments but sorry I'm getting lost on the farm
I didn't realize how much we expanded the last time I was here you know it's
really quite the expansion to the end of us know how to get to this temple is it
I'm looking at you guys climbing okay okay okay I'm falling
mm-hmm oh I'll debards tavern did I say I don't wait it's here the letters here
you know the light the letters this week come back come back gimme it where
is he going wait whoa wait whoa how did he do that I thought this was the only
way to go I'm an idiot okay right is it this I'm following them I don't know
where I've never played these levels so I know we've triggered a new one of them
and but yes they don't really have much fun behind the scenes stuff I kind of
boring stuff and we're preparing to get the audio manager and and then that
means I have no response to the tea and then I can focus on my reading and then
we can have content like all the time not that like I know I said I know it
might be like what do you mean like more content but I mean
I'm literally hazed by it there's so much reforming and I know like already
stream every single day but like it just means after a stream if I'm not like
recording anything or doing anything like I can actually like de-stress and
unwind type things so yeah you can help ink everywhere yeah more strong attack
basically yes it means like I can also and focus on like other things like for
example my donut on I need to rewrite the entire fucking thing sorry about em like
I literally need to rewrite the whole damn thing again and it's like these
small like little tasks that take time it's not going to be like stressful and
I'm trying to like fit it all in one thing and one go or anything like that
and it's like no I can like take my time and chill and I think we'll probably do
another review stream of it I'll be in passing though like I'll just be a
general review and look all the berries you harvest beans what the fuck I mean
I'm British no I'm Scottish you know I mean you know I mean the meme is so level
progresses on the other side of the top oh I found the church look up look up
replays I found the temple it's this way we're gonna go okay we're back at the
tavern getting absolutely steaming wine rescued something's happening wait were
we not here oh no have we been here before we're actually lost I can see
where the damn cast it at the temple is that we're supposed to be maybe through
that way
rest easy because the safest places Johnny's coming we'll answer them someone left a
really nice comment the other day on my pregnancy one they were like it's
actually normally like the community or whatever gets like made fun of for like
enjoying this stuff sorry whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa where's the enemy where's the
other one where's the other one I need to reload I'm in the tornado I'm in the
tornado I need to what's going on hold on I don't know where is did you get it I
don't know okay thank god friends fire on oh wait that's the guy there I got him I
got him I did it are we rescued up another way okay we did it we found where we're
actually supposed to go after him like what ten minutes we haven't played this
map okay all right well I haven't played this map I don't know if the reef and
time is this open we plan let me in I'm coming for you let me in you need your
daily inking oh so you're hissing at me something's whispering I like it oh the
nice comment they were like oh it was nice cuz normally like people make fun
of this but this was like the most wholesome thing ever and I'm like don't
think I won't make a to a pregnancy 2.0 I found it really sweet making it but I
don't know how else I would make it maybe it would just be like straight up no
talking but like my actual tummy sounds and heartbeat and nothing else and like
breathing or whatever and my head we're getting knock knock let us in we must go
around the door is unlocked I assure you okay we need to climb around
mean birthday some are you just screaming to the mic mmm fuck really
hey give me sequel and I'm like well that's logically the next week
oh oh find the map I will find the map I have not found the map I really like
that it was great context for looking forward to late which is the more
I really enjoyed it was just like what's going on in here secret secret door
secret map access secret map access go to the gate go to the gargoyle and then
touch the statue of death got it
that doesn't sound good we have to fight our way back escape the temple now
what do you mean escape the temple they're coming the British are coming the
British are coming that fight that fire can't hurt us right surely not
thank you thank you silly son's whisper in son's whisper in is it them I'm being
a spondent ray on me of course I'm freaking destroying you
right we're leaving the village we're leaving the village no way but this is
their farm how do we get out of here I didn't know whoa ow I'm getting moved
though yeah you're not the only one that can move
okay I'm just swinging okay okay okay okay I think I found the way yeah me's
light in the way the closer light in the way they're telling us we have to
leave the farm I can't believe it well we claim the farm another day we've got
the important stuff which was the four bottles of wine that's what we were here
for we got the wine we protected it okay thank you for hanging sorry you have
work you totally shouldn't do anything actually I should work on speaking of
work I should work on that next audio which is encouraging you bash it but
don't add I'm gonna have to put like tons of disclaimers being like don't
actually listen to this that work I'll cry if you've gotten trouble because of
me again why you need to drink this portion the dwarves of edible what are
you doing and I swam
Amy's music video should be coming soon to him and taking a hot second and what
we got there in the end of the semester I like contacted someone for I'm like hey
here's all the fails here's the job do you want to take it they said yes then
proceeded to ignore me for the next few days and I'm like no okay go wait he
calls I miss one we're on the path of already listen to the patron on you
can't stop me you listen to the word the intro I feel like it would be so
distract stand up shut up and shine oh wait no stand up shut shape of it or
shut up are you posing what was that hey you like opened your arms there what
do you I'm not allowed to use headphones at work mummies and alcohol like joke
joke oh dear oh you saved my I was not prepared for that follow the trail we
will continue down this beloved path I'm spanky oh my gosh we're going there
replaying I think the farm just got an upgrade there's no way we're going there
is this all in one mission I thought them can he be are we about to go in that
castle is that why these missions are like one pair act no the castles another
mission okay it's a future mission I was gonna see because I thought these maps
would be as tiny as they were but if it were going that far ahead in the map then
maybe the stream's gonna be a bit longer than our first and I said five hours for
the stream mentally oh it's a cooking cauldron I get to make my chicken stay I'm
getting the sun so born but I'm so excited for I'm getting a roast chicken from
willy's today I'm gonna I'm forcing myself to go outside because I've been
really bad and I may okay thank you I was gonna say I might be in trouble
refling and I'm getting a roost again but I can't realize I was giggling about
it yesterday I think it was yesterday I was like yeah I've not really been
outside in a long time and I'm like mmm maybe I need to push myself to go at
so I'm forced to match up to go to release and actually I don't know if I
said the I found out there's a thing here there's a healing here someone
see my sigma hello open dolly no you know we'll be cheating that's what we're
playing pull a lever I don't know what I did though open to the way why it's the
rickety bridge and shrek I'm a donkey on it no shrek I don't want to do it keep
going whoa there's new oh I'm getting good okay we're good what do you mean
we're playing on easy mode this is legendary this is the hardest mood that
you can play I heard that I don't know what I heard jump here
hello I just break to their spirit I guess an absolute spanking the
get right
easy peasy lemon squeezy mommy if you want to help to go outside maybe I could
hold your hand to make you feel bare why didn't you put me in a leash in color
that's terrible I shouldn't see such things as first thing in the morning
beam up
spanked him you didn't expect that did you know I ironically though I do need to
like walkies and he put myself for a walk and although the weather has been
more agreeable so I'll try to behave I could maybe go for a big walk are you
know yeah are you know I just get so tired and like I feel like if I do too
much and I'm not working like for the girls or whatever I'm like letting them
down somehow although saying that I don't think I have any work she's getting
close to doing a YouTube role play like that's kind of my responsibility if they
won and if they won like an ASMR role play like I'm happy to write it up and
edit and slap subtitles on it take thing no I'm gonna crazy things are
chilling out so I sent away seven shorts I actually still need to go through the
clip I had a lot of clips and I did not expect how many clips that had can you
not know and I'm throwing a nuke you're welcome
and I still have to go through the clip I didn't realize how much you guys were
like this funny moment so thank you I had a really just I had two burping clips
that were absolutely foul I was like right open your mouth reef lens and it
was like a 10 out of 10 burp that came out and I'm like there you go you're
welcome good boy I'm like oh my god sometimes I don't realize how like
meaning that I'm on stream and I'm like don't worry reef lens I'll tackle this
werewolf myself no no I assure you I can handle it that's the best part though
well I've asked for a highlight I'll see how it comes out how the short comes out
if it does well I'll keep ordering the burp ones like that but if it just does
alright I'm needing to make some pre-recorded shorts actually but I'm
going to come here come here can we not progress we need a way around the gate
you mean like this path right here you mean this path right here yes out there's
a healing thing here for any reason that needs to someone's game really weak I'm
gonna take this and then one of the reef ones can take that heel pack behind me
I'm gonna use it on themselves
ah okay we go all the way around your beloved minger oh my god honestly I'm
free from the grocery shop oh my god I can't believe you didn't let me come to
you put me in the troll actually go whoa oh we're to touch the statue okay so
instructions again I can't remember the instruction was oh you did it you did it
the real about how to make it explore the crit oh suspicious amount of medical
ooh gee willikers I sure don't hope we have a fight oh and ammunition I wonder
what's the head you mean the very demure path it's very considerate very open very
accessible wait what okay the one that has a head is what we're to go for all
heroes must be present all we're heroes we're holding up for you to the end of the
okay oh we need to okay no oh wavelength what did you do
this is giving room filled with enemies very shortly hmm it's ketchup season now
it's not dumb it I hear them I don't see some oh yeah jeez you're not refland
you're a baddie it's like it's like or everything's getting spanked now oh he's
stuck to me wait we must protect briefly must protect briefly I'm protecting I'm
protecting I'm doing a shade job I'm doing a shade job I repeat I'm doing a
terrible job terrible job little cheeky fire aoe love it there's so much blood
in the thing the frames block in the HP bar I will make the frame disappear after
quick segment oh oh oh oh oh oh oh ow something getting
where's the helmet I don't know where we're to go to get the helmet
I
Love very much out a hundred percent minus the DLC. We like on the variant of the collie
It's two down here, right? We must assist the reef like we must we simply must right where we're
Down you didn't give us more healing than this
Ah hopefully I'm helping and not making everything worse than making everything worse. I
Even know where you are we fun. I'm so sorry
Ah ink ink, but nothing not now another time
Now it's not the best time for me
Can you read okay, you can
Yeah
I'm spanking I'm spanking I promise
What's happening to him?
Hey, we're alone. He didn't mean it. I
Think they healed
Where we go down or reflect I think we go down well, we just go for it no heals
Oh
Something's hurting me
I'm
Have a hailing pack
Okay, maybe let me revive I have heels
And I
Who up part
How long does that last
Make me nervous
Going you're making me nervous
Oh
Here oh, that's where the spawn out. Oh, I'm
Claiming I'm claiming they're spawning. These are one point
Don't stand near the people the people. Oh, there's a yeah
That's so bright first thing in the morning, holy, okay, I think you're okay
Yeah
Oh
We can do it we can do it we can do it we can do it
Return to tell horn see what we're to go all the way around
Where's the witch don't I don't see him. I don't see him
Um unironically we're we can okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, that was rude we can even help
I think I heal like 15 HP or something. I can't remember there's something about my weapon if I would pick you up
I heal you by like one tiny number
Where do we go? No, no, no, no
Where is he
And this river supposed to go I
I
Thought we're playing easy mode. Where's all the oh, it's a way where it's okay. We're ready
Literally, that's so hard. I thought it was supposed to be an ignored inc. NATO this equal brother. It's so hard
Old
Danzo complete
I'm a level 19 collect loot dice 20
Pes and stone box I do
I'm gonna very quickly run and go get a cola. Okay, don't worry. I don't need to mute
I
Special kills 14
I like oh my gosh actually go accolades now hold on a minute melee kills
I got damage to monsters headshots and most revives see told you I was a medic
I'm forcing you guys to play overwatch with me in like a month's time
When general comes out, we're doing overwatch
At the end of friend request, okay, we're gonna return to la creep
Very the Grimoire's make it harder. Let me add
For fuck's sake. What was that? Was that that bloody fox?
That was that bloody fox
Thank you for playing replants. Is there any other reasons that one in I think so
Thank you. Thank you. Thank you. Thank you. Thank you. Have you eaten? Thank you? Oh
Well, okay, boom boom boom
That kills me I ain't gonna make it
Okay hydration check
Okay new batch of I'd say fodder, but you guys are keeping me alive. So maybe I'm the fodder
Look I am your
Head empty so we've got Cali we've got head empty no thoughts
No thoughts I'm just
short-handed it and then a
Yeah
And together your names will be
Together the team will be
Do you want to be called a can of sprite and a sore thumb
The iconic boss, thank you for the extended membership sub guys. Yes as a guy
Hydration check more like piss-making session. Whoa when you put it like that. I
Can't a sprite in a sore thumb captain's a monitor crazy Jesse. I think the fox is cute
Everyone that's the beautiful thing about humanity everyone is entitled to their own opinion
Some people would claim
That the Tiberian fox
Looks like it was drawn from memory
Without knowing what fox really looks like and some would argue that it's cute and that's okay
We have to celebrate our differences
That's thank you
Um, okay. I open box
And then I'll name the team and then we will mission select
Well
I've got an arrow. I don't really use an arrow
It looks Tai betan it is Tai betan
Um, what are you?
Damage resistance versus rats is way up. Oh, I thought I knew gun that can actually put on. What the fuck is that?
Is that a weapon? No, you're fucking with me. That's not a weapon
What are you? Oh, I literally thought that was a weapon. I was like you're fucking with me refill and there's no way that's a weapon in game
Okay, we've got 80 on now
Let's really get in trouble
This does more damage
Wait, what?
Assisting an ally under attack restores 15 temporary health
I don't know. I feel like that's more advantageous than the team
Oh, that's we there and then the trinkets the same. Okay. Let me go mission select and then I will name our team
Which will be
Wait, what?
No, yeah, I don't know how I messed up
Ah, okay blood in the darkness
Blood right. Okay. The game reads out. Yes. We're playing. No. I'm yes. We're doing legendary mode. How do you?
I was gonna say yes or no
Oh, you have a piglet. Oh, wait. No, that's not a refill. That's an NPC. Um, right
What should the name be?
I do a combination legendary modes
Well, I call us legs and dairy because we're obviously
Should I call us cheese? I'm gonna call us cheese
Because we're cheese in the level because we're supposed to be playing legendary
But we're not and legendary sounds like dairy and dairy and cheese is a dairy product
Get a cheese. Cheese gang. Cheese gang. I'll call us cheese gang
Just call every team a different type of cheese grommets
Enter the outer bastard should have picked bastard
Should have picked any kind of support. We ended up green and
Green
Just call him team stinky
No
refunds aren't stinky
I I am the one who pheromone max is instead of I am the one who knocks
I'm the one who pheromone max is
I
Let's go find your way to the get out all
The gaoui what is the gaoui? I don't know
I'm learning. I'm learning
Nope, what?
I'm interested if necessary here
Oh my goodness, I'm gonna get turned around so much praying one of the refunds applied this before
Oh
My gosh places massive
I got
I like sniping a game I find it satisfying
There's that sniper game that I want to play with you guys because uh, I can't remember what it's called drop
It was like a really critically clean like everyone enjoyed it thoroughly and it was a sniper game
Sniper elite and maybe
And maybe
I'm not sure strongy indeed snakes. I am the one who snakes
I am the one who don't
I'm the one who come well not recently because I'm stressed again
I can't I I don't ink anymore. I've lost my belly to ink again
Not looking good
Oh, I told him
I found a book
Yeah
Literally, I live vicariously through you. I like read my marshmallows and I'm like, oh, yeah. Oh, that's given me life. Oh, yeah
I actually just put that keg open I'm sorry
Oh, well, who did that? Who hit that keg? Honestly
Who did that shorten behavior?
Whoopsie
That's a good Darren. Whoa. Oh jeez
Let's wait up
We're waiting
How are you there? Did you just drop down?
Oh, shit. I'm sorry. I'm not smart reflin. Please help me. I'm sorry. Thank you
How are you standing there like this way?
You gotta wrap around or wrap around
I'm following give me
Oh
My villain arc
ah
So my little my little shortcut wasn't quite it wasn't wrong
It wasn't quite right. Okay. Sometimes in life you can you can be right and wrong
Oh, there's a kid it's on fire
Ah
Wow
Oh my god, that gun is crazy
Aren't these called stalagmites
And then if it's on the ceiling it's called something else
But it sounds really similar to each other if it's on the roof and it's on the bottom
Whoa
There's titties on the ceiling
I
Don't my future remodel maybe didn't translate all that well. I'll extreme for the joke
Stalagmate standing
Stalag kiddies clinging to the ceiling. I mean, who wouldn't want to look up if he wouldn't
A troll troll in the dungeon
Oh
Is this the time really I'm swinging and whoo I found it. I found it. It's here
Uh, well, it's gone away again. He ran away. I promise. I'm not losing it. I literally saw it. I literally saw it
Oh you go you go I'm highlighted
Oh
Refling please be careful
I should be careful. No, don't take the book out. Ah
I'm stuck. I'm cornered. I'm cornered
Hey, what I'm stuck. I'm stuck
Troll stuck troll stuck
Oh, oh, get me out of there. Jeez
You're freaking stuck. Oh wait my layout is covering my health. How do I cover?
Is it this one?
I did it right on the first try. I'm so smart. There you go. Now you can see what I'm looking at
I have a control
I literally got
Spewed on wow. He has good aim. It's almost like he's here
Oh
It's tip his there. I'm stuck
Grip up grip on me after
We're grouping we're grouping
We're grouping so hard right now
Oh
We're doing it we're doing it
This is
I'll actually after this one. I'll count how many missions there are left
Because I really don't think it's that many like I think after the act one
aim
Do not relent on your slay slay
Okay, I think that now that the gates open escape run run refling
We must flourish to the cast in
Oh, I know we're in the castle now. We must be
There's some in
Okay
Okay, okay, okay, let me get up. Let me get up. I don't know what I'm doing
Oh, wrong way. There was a staircase to the right. There was a staircase to the right to the right to the right to the right
Up the stairs up the stairs
Nice try nice try don't waste my time
I didn't know they had crawlers in this game
That's right. The one thing that is you know for
Automatically I need help
Is it going for a boost?
What are you doing? I'm going for whoop
What were they doing to these bodies?
They do not care
Oh no refling I'm not there to help
I'm helping I'm helping
I'm came to help
Oh, we can do like a 360 run
Okay, we have grimoire
Hey, I heard that there's something ahead careful. Oh, are these guys?
That sounded a lot more dangerous. Oh, it's him
Ah, I did it. I blocked I did it. Are you proud of me? I blocked in time in the face
Reach the surface. Yes, we can reach the surface. No problemo
Ah, I'm so proud of myself
I blocked the enemy and to aim
An MLG
Uh, does anyone need healing the elf needs healing elf you need to heal in the most
Where is elf
There's elf elf heal elf heal now
I'm ready. I'm defending right, let's go
This is worse than the smell
I could make the most vile joke right now, but I just want you to know that I'm referring raining
Is it down or up? Oh, no, it says reach the surface up up go up
I'm lurking to say proud of you blocking. Thank you
Shawnee has a filler
I've already forgotten what the elf said should it taste work
It tastes worse than it smells or something like that
And it was like reefing after realizing that pheromone maxing doesn't mean I taste better. I taste worse
Like I'm sure there's like a grosser way. I could have said that but I forgot already
And it was really obvious, okay, there's a boot buy a sigma
Wait, did they just not go for the captives or are they just like pretending like
Whoa
What a strange
You get
Hey some will taste okay. I think mold you think I got mold on me
Oh, no, no, no, did you save them?
Central
It is a book here. I'm full so I can't pick it up
It's just marionade little marionade never hurt and it adds flavor
He
Penicillin comes from all the guys. Oh, we should do a pen. We should do the wonders of modern medicine stream
And then I can talk about how penicillin came from a tweet
and then the rise of
antibiotic resistant
bacteria, which is naughty
Because viruses don't respond to antibiotic
And if you don't finish the course either you just are infected with
more
It's actually
Oh sweet man-made horror beyond my comprehension
It's not really it's by accident
and
But like I don't know if it's in a same four different areas, but in Britain. Um antibiotics are
Regulated like you have to go to the doctor to get them
Um, and they won't grant you them if you present with symptoms of like viruses or whatever
Um, you have to like prove basically that you've got like a bacteria issue going on because that's what the antibiotics are
anti-bacterial
anti-biotics
And bacteria is alive whereas viruses aren't alive
and
viruses are like
When you have a cough and it's sneezing stuff
and oh no
Hey disconnected wait someone just wait am I going no wait idiot idiot
That's I'm an idiot. Don't look at me. Don't look at me. I'm dumb
I
Thought there was a decent
Where was that?
I lost you're free
Yeah, we have a ball. Oh no, what's happened?
What happened how did I only just notice the snow?
That makes sense because over use of antibiotic can be more. Yeah
Can I invite you back in oh, that's a human sorry
I
See me can join a game in progress another book is here
The knee it convinced the bot to pick it up
I disconnected yeah, I don't know if you got the invite to try and come back in
Hmm
Oh wait the bot knows how to pick up boots
No way you got that kill you stole it if you order them to oh, it's working
Wait, you can't come in even though I'm invited
Oh
I see you. Whoa. No, I broke the door. I was gonna close in their faces
The bot's have smart pain
What we supposed to do down here we're supposed to come here there come here there
All heroes must be in this area. Yes
Oh, we're searching
Point to a book and press tango
I'm hacking you flashy flashy flashy
No, uh, I Rissa actually sent me a new short to upload
I'm sorry. You can't fool me. I know you will taste amazing after some pheromone maxing
No, that is not how
How choochies work. Thank you giving kitsune, but replaying
The the choochie is an enclosed system. Okay, everything has to expel from it. Okay
So pheromone maxing. Uh, uh, I snuck and taste it. Am I not supposed to?
I'm uh, I'm holding us up. Thanks
No, don't be putting the lick in them. Oh, it's bad
I hear them like really badly hear them
Last book is coming up and we had to do in the hard mode
A closed ecosystem indeed. No
Like I was memeing the other day, but you I think you can technically make bread with your own
Your own supply, you know, they normally say don't get high on your own supply, but
Uh
Yeah, uh, can any of us pick it up?
All right, I'm gimme gonna pick it up
Bread, beer, it's all yeast
They say the stink of the cheese the better it tastes so maybe the same goes
No
Drinking karma, no
That's terrible
Thank you for the the tip, but no, am I going the wrong way? Am I not supposed to go this way?
or
He just did a funny roundabout
You expel it and we swallow it beeflings you did not take nutrition from that
I don't care if you're I say full of oh no, you might because you're a deep sea life form and they take
Nutrients from anything
Thank you
You're
Ramin
Gramin for becoming a member. That's right. I said that right. I said it's so right. Hmm
Gramin's all over you
Okay, I'm gonna heal
And then I'm gonna pick up the boots
Got it
Hey, we're accurate. Hello potential. No
Hey, if we can eat century eggs, why not? I heard about that
Ritual chamber
Oh, I didn't pick the book up. Oh, no
No, wait, what wait what happened? Wait, I'm confused. I don't have wait
Did that reflin take the book off of me?
I'm back
Am I going mental?
The reason pick up oh
Oh
Whoops
Survive right we're gripped up. We're safe. Although I think you need this more than I do
I shouldn't be gonna work
Uh, uh
Uh, I'm getting killed
I'm I'm helping. I'm totally helping right now. I'm helping so much
Truly
Look at that one kill one kill. I'm helping my teammate
If you need an example of what pheromone maxxing looks like take one look at the place
Honestly real unsure I had to shower yesterday
Because I did a big massive poopy
And I was like damn I need to show up to that
And you don't tell him the truth because I'm laughing
I really want a Japanese toilet like that comes with this the day things and like it plays like music for you and everything
And
Oh, I can't see that enemy. I have no idea where that enemy that's from that
At least the bread came out fine
That's what if I go for a walk and all that I refland ink everywhere
Carve them up smash them in back into the ink I go
Shawnee shivered she hates this I do not I do not I assure you
I
The one that pressure washes your crack
I so badly want a Japanese toilet like the lid opens up apparently it comes with a seat warmer
That's luxury. You know that's like
If I ever became a millionaire there would be signs and I would be showing off my Japanese toilet
I've been so freaking happy in that thing. Why?
How's any bombs?
Please
Please please drop the refling. We don't have heels. Oh good. No
Oh, she's sorry. You scared me
It please
Since when there was a plea I'm not I'm not kidding
There's genuinely the Japanese toilets like plea music to hate your your tinkle sounds and stuff
And it also like can beat when it welcomes you like it senses when you enter and it'll open up
And you can like set the seat to warm when it's winter
So your butt's all nice and warm and you have to wake up and take a tinkle in the middle of the night
Because you drank too much
Oh, we did it. No way we did that. We have all books
All books and two totems
mlg
I'm almost shiny. So cute. Hope you get one. Yeah, like look, I'm not here looking for a Lamborghini
I'm not here looking for a y'all. I'm not here looking for this. You know what? I want a humble Japanese toilet. That's what I want
That's all that's what I crave in life
All Japanese, but I actually don't even know how to get one, but you never know
The art and take of the shitter truly the best
It well, I used to really annoy my mum and I used to run the water like the tap every time I took a shit
I don't know why I used to be so embarrassed about the sound of it. So I used to run the tap
So now I'm used to hearing running sounds
I work in a Japanese restaurant and we had two B days, but one already broke in less than a year
Can't do good things in America. Oh
That's terrible. I'm sorry to hear that. Also. Thank you quest as well for the super chat
So I have been absolutely not on point with being like following the rules of being strummer
I've been doing shit
Um, absolutely terrible
Absolutely terrible. All right. I got completely carried. What did I do damage to monsters?
How?
Because I got pinned in the corner
I'm getting out. I'm getting rewarded with that shopping
Oh a hydration check I need water
I
Battered the trolls head as it pinned me to the wall like fucking
Thank you, thank you cheese gang cheese gang for the full tombs full booked run. That was a good one
Okay, let me check. Let me check
Bing boom bat, but a big bang pow
What is your name? Oh, okay, right first dead
First dead then resurrect
Is that your full legal name? Be honest first dead then resurrect is your full legal name. Then we got zero
And then we got kush master. What the fuck? Okay, we've got kush master
420 mlg nice
Why are you dox me? Okay. I the group the team name is going to be your full legal names. Okay
So first dead
Then resurrect wait, what was it? What the fuck did I call you first dead then resurrect? Gosh. Um
My brain is not having it zero deaths for 20 mlg
Right, what's in it? Okay an energy freezes. Oh baby a triple
But we've got someone called zero so what oh baby a zero kill because it says first dead and dead means killed so
Okay, this group is oh baby
A zero kill. What a unique name for a team
I'm sorry if I sound tired. I'm struggling to wake up. I've had a tea. I've had sugar
And my arse isn't awake yet. What you mean? Okay
The in canter's lair so that we're about to finish that one that one only has two this one has four so at least there's
Sam can tense juice
Wait, so you bought the dlc. I can't believe it
They tricked you they advertised to you so well
First zero for turning
One will grow to be to verment I can be pretty tired
Clap it so it wakes up. You want me to clap my cheek?
Want us to wake your arse
Since you mentioned sound about plain overwatch when the new Juno Juno is out. I just want to let you know wait Juno's out right now
Haha, what if I made us all install even more spyware and we play a little of overwatch together
Wait, you want me to get up and clap right now. I don't even know if I could do it. Hold on. Hold on. I need I've got
I've got
Oh, no, it's not working. Wait, hold on. It's in my head. It's because I've got a big video on hold on. Hold on
Like I'm good at performing
I'm good at performing under
I still got it, baby
Okay, I stood up. Surely this will get the blood pool and wake me up and not keep me asleep
Oh
Oh my god, wait, maybe we should do that after overwatch if we win again
Uh
If we win an overwatch
I do a round of applause after every time we win, but if we don't win you get spit in your mouth instead
How about that that's how we'll do overwatch
So if we lose you have to open your mouth and let me spit in it and if we win I give you a round of applause
No, they can't get past the guards because of those
This one is the um
Where's the punishment? It sounds like a win-win to me installing overwatch right now
Oh, look at that pause
Centurion hit. Oh heads with a sigma. What was that once again?
No, I've just fucking taped that and don't read the don't read the chat and game. I've just messed up again
His mummy finally learned to block sometimes
but he lowered sometimes
No, not again
I do it every time in this game. I don't know how
Um, but I didn't realize Juno was out. I thought she was like still a month away
We made it to the castle
Oh
Not posing at the door like yeah, this is the way I'm yeah use the omelot wheel
I have entered the castello
Uh, they really didn't want to spruce up the place did they poison feast chalice. Why not?
Poison feast chalice, uh, I'm not really sure I like the decor. You need to make this place a bit more inviting, don't you think?
See, what does that say? See if anyone answered
Oh
Oh, but I actually scared me
I was gonna pretend to push the door open a bit faster. That actually scared me
What a baby honestly
Baby
Is it over which one or two I have terrible news for you refling
They killed overwatch one
To make two they like merged to the server and pretended that overwatch two is like a new game
It it wasn't the overwatch two is literally just
They just added like battle pass and stuff into
I'm sorry. You had to find out this way
My thoughts are with you at a time like this. I I'm sorry. It's just how it is
They
Overwatch one doesn't exist
There is no easter bunny. There is no toast fairy and there never was an overwatch two
It's just a package
Coblet
Okay, so the reason why you always swing in this game is because an enemy might pop out and you'll do damage at any point
But if you don't
Swing you're never going to do the damage
Find a way back to the castle. Oh, because we're in the crypt
What was that I found it
Um, is this a dead end I'm following you. Okay. I think none of us have played this map. Okay. I'm following you guys
Right, let's go back down here
Whoa, I actually got wallet
Oh, wait, no, there's something here. Hold on a minute. Oh, no, you're friendly
Uh
I assumed her to go up
Oh, oh no, we've reached the bone warrens. Oh, no, no, we're not going that way
Truly your friends, do you think keeping them alive makes up for all the rooms you've failed?
Why we got brain worms in this game?
And not this game having in-game brain worms. What the heck?
Become debuff find a way I'm finding a way at Drayshman's vaults
Come on
I'm spamming I'm spamming
No straggler straggler no struggling. No replay. Are you okay?
I like that the rats can talk
I
When you feels you're no match for queens with fire
Wait till she finds the
psychers in dark tide are completely mad
Well, like psychic people are just straight up mad and no one believes them or is psychers something
Mm-hmm
Hold on I give my a little itch itch out. Sorry. I was itching my hair
Oh
Wait, so does everyone get like a specific thing mad as info balloon skit's trying it. Well
Um, we're doing it. We're doing it. Yeah, fuck that door. Fuck it up
Perish that door. Okay, there's heel. Oh chalice. Hello
I got five chalice
They draw in power from
Yeah
God this gun is OP
Do we jump down? Is this third to the halls grand feast hall? Okay. Yes. We are
It's mine now. Fuck you
Oh, let's blow it to smithereens. Where's the keg? Oh, you already got it. Wait
Oh, oh
Is there a secret chalice in this room?
Oh, they're exploding out the hall
How undesirable
Yeah, the voices and the head change based on I was gonna say because it doesn't make sense for
The guys would be going at me like, oh, how many fuck are you?
trained
Of carillions like what you own a bit
Oh dad like my coffers being full
You
Wait, am I the only one that hears it? Why did she I say are you all right?
Am I deathwind?
Or does she not hear she's already mental
Kind of wait were you posing on the stairs?
Stop, how do you do that so quickly?
I don't know how you do that. You must have changed. Stop in the middle of a fight
Okay, I'll beat him up beat him up beat him up
Maybe she's not weird. She's being corrupted by chaos. She can't stop herself
I was somewhat annoying since warhammer fans in fortcare both within the universe but far away from each other
Yet chaos gods have always been there but also haven't been there
They're just feeling a bit quirky, you know I hear
Oh
I'm coming. I'm coming. Give us a second. Give us a moment
I saved the replaying you're welcome
High five
You're to heal them. Yeah
Okay, we'll have an
They were a little corky
Ah, that's so blinding
I really can't even wake up
this morning
Am I dreading having to actually
I bet you that's what it is. I'm going out. I'm like, maybe not
Although I'll tell you something noody that I did yesterday instead of working full. I did um
I don't know if you guys watch Caleb hammer
It's like this guy that looks into people's finances and then he goes
You're voluntarily putting yourself in debt, right?
But he had an episode where he had this guy come on
But he was having a really difficult time
like with
I don't know
I don't know what the diagnosis is, but it's rough
How much t of you in jesset? Whoa. Whoa. What was I don't even know what that was
I think I thought grabbed by something and you saved me. Thank you refling. You're my only hero
Hey, will I ever repeat you? I must shag you as payment
Where did that go? I saw it
I'm going mental. I saw that. Did it do? Ah, there is. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. I saw you coming on mail early
As a corner financial point, I love Caleb hammer's content
I just find it interesting to see how like other people live
um
Cuz I'm always going to eat shit
Bomba
Oh shit, you just pulled them up to smithereen
Um
Cuz uh, I'm very lucky to be in a position where um, I don't have a credit card and
Cuz I fucking
How can you be a king in this universe that doesn't make anything
Ah stop it
This map is confusing no matter how many times I play it. No pressure. We're looking at you
It looks like we're supposed to go there
I'm on oh wait
I don't know what to do
credit cards are a scam basically
Wow, that's so bright. Um
Basically, yes
But I understand obviously why people need them like but I just fucking hate them
I like credit score as well. Sorry. I cannot help be tinfoil. I can I go one stream without being tinfoil?
I'll go this way. Okay. We're t-posing over here
If I could go one stream without being tinfoil that would be grand
Ritualists are sent
Never
There's no pressure. Is that the pressure credit cards must be the most you spend without noticing how much you spend
yes, so um
If you had the physical money to see how much like you hand over etc
I think a lot of people would be like absolutely mortified at how much they hand over for like certain things
But it's all like
the benefit of the credit card companies and all that like
You know like back in the old day if you had literal like gold in that and you'd have to put it in storage like
You know if people could see the vast amounts of physical wealth that others have like that's why the guillotine was a thing
Yeah, no
No, I'm not saying
That that's the thing but what I'm saying is once money became
Like numbers on a screen as it advanced with technology
It it can hide
wealth and it can also like it can hide wealth to be the at the advantage of
um
The high table basically
But it can be such a disadvantage to the average joe because you don't realize like how much is coming out of your coffers type thing
and um
Honestly, there's probably a lot of like mentality about it as well
Because if you had to like so say you get your paycheck and you took it all out in cash
And then you handed your landlord the rent in cash
And then you went to the shop and paid for everything in cash
Um, and like you could see it go down so dramatically you'd be like what i'm not spending money on x y z elemental p
um
So yeah, sorry
Sorry, I know I sound really the fact that i'm actually really tired right now and still i'm able to
call
Come like come out with a sentence around tin foil hat now
I could just kind of help myself honestly canny just put me in the bin put me in the bin. I've uh, I don't know
I need to learn to shop. So at some point I really do
um
I'm
Whoa, where did you come from? Yeah, two of us can shield bash. I might not have a shield but i'm bashing anyway
a chandelier
Hmm, how curious we've been offered health potions right everyone heal up heal up over here
They're not healing up fine. I'll heal up
Stressing me out
Boss fight upcoming
Am I not cooking
You're actually right money is actually just a number for actually
Get ready for one of those boss fights of all time. Don't say that. Is that a werewolf? Please be a werewolf
Whoa, whoa, whoa is this physical responsibility?
uh
Depends on what your situation is right that's it. I'm delving into the refueling bank account to make sure that uh
You're self sustaining and you're not undead and then you're allowed to
Then you're allowed to be the inquester of the werewolf. Thank you
Bed of ear bed of ear
I'm trying. I'm sure I'm saying it wrong
Huh
Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa. You can't just come from all directions
Now hold on a minute
Why
Whoa, whoa, whoa
Now hold on a minute. Excuse me sir
Ah, what happened to my crosshair
Oh, we're all through it. What is that me that's doing that? Am I messing this up?
I'll be naughty
I think I'm messing this up a wee bit, but I'm trying my best
Is that do anything?
It keeps making me look to the ground when he does that. Am I supposed to do something?
I'm popping a drink. Sorry. I need a drink to comprehend what on earth I'm doing wrong
Did I need to be in the circle?
Stand out of the orange. Oh, you mean that super
massive hint
That's really obvious to most video gamers to not stand in and I keep standing in it. Oh
Okay
Thank you
I don't know why it takes me so long to figure out mechanic
I'm doing it
Literally with
Bios, wait, what stand out of the orange stand out of the orange
I'm swinging. I'm swinging. I'm stunning. I'm stunning. I used my ultimate, but I don't know if that helped
I'm doing it. I'm doing it. I'm dodging. I'm dodging. I'm spanking. I'm spanking
Oh
Wakey wakey my pretty and be another 4am stream
We're wrong. Sorry. That's the gate. Wait. These are all gate. It's a riddle. Oh, it's a lever. Sorry
There is a lever on the wall
Nicely done. We're getting through this castello is going down
Oh
Where the heck is the lever?
It's not it's like a
Okay, okay, we make it up. We make it up. We're doing it. We're doing it
We're doing it
Oh, it's art in here. Oh, it's so pretty
That should not come into the cage
I might as well. No mommy, please. My sleep. Literally
Thank you, wakey. Time for another endurance stream at 4am
Yeah, I'm really happy with how Slonic Heroes went yesterday. I was
secretly actually really worried I wouldn't be able to do the end
But like I was rolling and smoking that game. It's a child's game. No, stop. Stop. Don't ruin it for me
I did really good. I never went against metal sonic before. I didn't even know it was a thing
And then I rolled and smoked um, yes
It took me a while to figure out that I can't hit them with the same color on the button on the side of the suit
I'm
I got a job interview
What do you need to do? What do you need to do for a job interview?
Basically fucking smoke up that. Oh, yes. I'm very self-sufficient. If you need a cv unironically
Send I will pretend that you're on the dev team
If you need a cv
I'm gonna make a throwaway email and you guys can ask for cvs and I'll make up the most best bullshit ever
So wake up. I'm a real gamer girl. Yeah, I'm not doing it for male attention for one
Even though I'm getting completely carried through the game. Does that make me a real gamer?
Merchant strong bot
Headshots and special skills
Still pre-recorded streams though. Strongly the ultimate job wingman
For one exactly
All for male attention caught me in 4k
She said I do but we did it. Thank you team
Uh, oh baby a zero kill. Who names these teams?
Clearly they need to be kicked off of any development team that requires naming of any source
Hmm. Hmm. Yes
I can't wait. I can't wait to get obliterated
But I already got obliterated for fondal abysm. So actually there's no there's no need right. I'm not open
No
You type fondal abysm in game chat. I was tazin
Pre-recorded stream for the brats. I did it
How's that for a I pre-recorded
Hmm
The strong e365 stop that's such a shite me
Oh, I got an even better gun. I was a 10 out of 10 for you. Yeah. Yeah, you like that. That's pretty
sugar
Fucking actually look look. Okay. Let me make sure there's no other
No, we got we've got quits in this team and then two more we flim if there's any available
I know it's the week a weekday. So please don't worry if you can't join
um
Wait, why's that?
What do you do?
I'm gonna just my hero power is almost 300 now
Oh, it's so close to being 300 power
Power from hero level 200 power from equipment 91
effect damage dealt number of enemies penetrated by attack
And stagger level hero power is defined by your hero level and the average value of your equipped gear
Um strong e4 20 believes it. How do we join by the way? You just add me on theme
And then you snipe into the lobby and then that's it
Others are but empty reflections of his blood you invite yourself into the lobby
Like you can join the lobby. You don't have pen in this pre-recorded brap clip
So you want your items to go to 300 as fast as possible and hero level 35. Oh, what happens then?
and then
So we have quits we have cloud rest and we have
cry
And
I'm probably absolutely but you're lucky
Quest
Load ref and one that can hardly read like a dumbass. What?
Why does it not see in the
Gang gang gang
You'll have seen that the 20 have you grabbed your chest
Yeah
From the book
I don't know why I like post so harshly on it. I don't have anything
Challenges
Oh, I got it
Is it that one?
Oh, I got these ones
Is that all you've got
Jailbreaker complete blood and darkness on the career difficulty
Oh enchanted lair
Oh, the lair was enchanted
It's like draw the attention and scapegoat by interacting with scaper attack three times
No, that's game
Slam reward
get your gate on a period kill spain mangler on the trip
Try and demonetize uh
Unlock your first talent point. Oh, yeah
Uh, wait, it's like yeah firing up wait, I have like a billion chests
Is there not like collect all please
Please I haven't been collecting any there's so many please
Please there's so many
So mama, do we just join when there is a spot available or do we wait until it's our turn?
So we finish
Round and then whoever gets in gets in but there's no repeats if that makes sense
So like once you've played around you're not allowed to play another until we've established that everyone's played that one is to play
Hey, thank you stash power. You can ask these questions for free. Stop giving me money for questions
You so what how many chests?
Oh, no, it's cuz I didn't I didn't do any of them
I'm trying I'm trying to clean them complete
I don't know what the purple is. I am clean. Okay. I did it. I did it. Okay. No, you can open them all
Oh, right. How about we open this one first considering there's only one of them
There's a claim all button guess who missed it
Okay continue and then we're gonna oh we opened five at a time. We can't even open them all
Oh, I got a one
That's not the gun I like to use and either's that and either's that
Try again unimpressed try again
That's better
That's better. Not bad. Not bad. Try again. Try again. Try again
Uh-huh. Mm-hmm. Mm-hmm. Oh, yeah. Mm-hmm. That's what I like to see. That's what I like to see, baby
Uh uh uh oh we're going up. We're at 102 now and I am
Um
And we've got uh charm. Okay, we did it right and then we're gonna go inventory
I'm gonna put that bad boy on yeah
Damn these are some upgrades
I've been taken to
Drinking a potion grants the effect of all other potions
Duration reduced by 50. So last what two seconds then?
I even drink potions to be honest
Wait one
Well, we have three two six for power
And we've got a point. Okay
Right land reaper increases power by 15% when paystrike is active. I have no idea what that is
Enhanced training pace strikes increase
Attack speeds by 20. I don't even know what pace break is
Pace straight. What's the pace straight spreads to nearby allies?
Do 112
1121 for tower
No
Sometimes it's funny me some Brian's way out of
Brian is having a hoot and holler. It's a passive pace strikes is your passive. It's on the right
Hitting three enemy. Oh, so pace strike spreads to nearby allies. Yeah, that's a good one
Yeah
Would you say you hear Sigmar's voice clear these days meet not his voice not to the bottom
Okay, this team is going to be called after the mission the treacherous adventure
We're going to be called the treasure seekers
treasure
Seekers
And then we're playing easy mode. I said was it
Are we ready? Are we steady? These are the refunds. He's lurking in the shadows up there
It's there with bigger weapons so bigger equals more
I was going to ask want to see a magic trick here
The refland taught me that last stream fake refling identified
You didn't watch the other stream, did you?
And then you get teleported to the cat. Yeah, that's right. I'm on you fake reflin
I'm not fake. I have a day job. Okay. That's different
Okay, it's different. I forgive you the reflin show me that the other stream
Oh, I never did it. I don't really do it pre-retro. Mwah. Mwah. Mwah. Okay. I'll kiss
Ain't nothing worse than being called a fake reflin. Oh, I'm sorry. I'm teasing if I am I would never actually call you a fake reflin
I completely comprehend
I put in too much
I put in I stream like so much. It's not possible to keep up. Sorry. I don't actually mean fake reflin. I'm teasing. Please. I'm sorry
I'm sorry
I didn't mean a we've let no because you're gonna make us both upset
Oh my god, we're in scotland
A fake link no
I don't even know how you be a fake link
Oh
Because if you're here then that kind of just proves you're a leaf
Like even if you're a vod watcher or you clip or you just like tweets in general. I'm not a fake reflin. I'm a freaklin
I'm a freak
Find the missing cargo
I
Wish I could wake up. I just can
I'm like exhausted but I slightly what six hours
Where did the cargo? Yeah, we're did the cargo. Oh, fuck. I did that too early
Don't listen to the same board. I didn't mean it. I hit it too early. I didn't
I didn't set up the joke. I didn't set it up in time
My brain's not fast enough
I I'm very epee. I think I'll go for a nap after stream
And then I'm gonna get my chicken and then I'll take a picture of the chicken and put it onto it
Wait, I was I was like, I don't know what to put on twitter. I've sometimes feel like I want to use it like
I
only like
Wait, what?
Refling, were you in that?
Why is that walking away from us?
What you help
Were you in that or am I going mental and we have to go chase that?
I'm gonna buy so I'm gonna buy the chicken and then when I finish the chicken, I'm gonna make soup
And then I'll show you my soup. How about that? I'm gonna get potatoes. Sorry. I really like soup
I'm just really passionate about soup. Okay, so I'm gonna get potatoes. I'm gonna get carrots
Celery is really good for bulking up soup as well. I'm gonna see if I can get um
Ah, what is it? It's not chicken broth stock. It's like
Bully on I'm gonna see if I can grab some bully on. Um
Oh other veggie tabels, I don't know a few carrots just look so rough
Go there
Um, I'm gonna get some legumes like the
Lentils lentils not the goons. I'm putting lentils in it like those we carrot based lentils
and
Your mission is to get the cargo from the city
I
Um
So basically once I've finished with the chicken
I've put it um, I boil the bornstone for the base of the bra and it'll taste absolutely delicious
And and then I'll show pictures of it because I'll be really proud of it and if I taste it and it's not nice. I'll be really sad
Oh
Oh, I didn't want to I didn't want to upset anyone, but there's a big ass
A starfiend
Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, hold on. I got you refilling hold on got it got you
Nice nice nice we're done
Real reefland's like strong. He's tasty. She's fairly nice
Ah, I gotta look that way
Oh, but delicious, I hope so
And then if it's really good, I might even share the recipe because I'll be so confident that you guys will love it
And then we can oh, and then we can eat the same food together
And we can be super healthy because soup is really good for you
Uh, I'm gonna get
Painters, I think to put the soup in and if it goes really really well
I'm just never gonna stop making soup because it means I will be eating super duper healthy
I'll get it. I'll be eating super healthy
I thought it was a nice idea
Oh jingle bells jingle bells jingle all the way
Oh, what fun it is to put right on the christmas sleep. Hey jingle bells jingle bells
Are we being spoken to?
Where's the runner
A soup bear joke
I love puns, but that was super bad
It's
Okay, I will be
Brave goal and I'll post my soup on twitter because I don't normally like post personal
Like shit I do after stream
Like I don't want to spam the feed and I like what I like that the girls post a lot because they always post interesting stuff
And we're like how they're doing or what's going on with them
um
And like I like using it to be like, oh mercy's ASMR roleplay like here's a teehee funny tip
But if you want to listen to it like I actually cut my hair for it
So, you know, you're welcome to listen like or like I'll on my alt account like I'll retweet everyone's butts
Um
The thing like I just like letting the girls do the the tweeter is like I just used to her for
Checking all
I just I don't really use it for much. I'm a simpleton
Oh another okay, I like this mission. It feels very winter wonderland together
Oh
I'm getting yanked I'm getting yanked and there's an assassin on me too
Teehee. I'm getting pulled out of bounds not to uh, not to stress any reefling out. I am
Getting pulled through the map
Oh
That's right. I actually joined a bd call in with fiji. I made you
Oh, I was feeling a bit quirky. Okay. I was feeling really really quirky
I
Falled from ruin
I miss my shoulder reeflings the fiji take you made me. It was so cute. I bet you they were like, why are you strong?
Brian write all my jokes down on paper because they're terrible. I'll see myself out
Thank you pretty lord. It's not that bad
Yeah, I didn't realize at first. They were like who is that
No, it's not your fault reeflings. It's not your fault
It's okay. It's not your fault
It's okay
It's not your fault
So
I literally write through the map as well
You vomit
Oh
How can you rescue a corpse? I fell under the map. How can you rescue me? That doesn't make sense
We don't mind you spam nerf either. Oh
Is this the first time you've died on stream in this game? It was a glitch. Oh, I'm here. Wow. How did you do that?
I'm back
I'm feeling like a hundred. I'm feeling like a million bucks. Oh, yeah magic. Yeah, okay. We back in it
Let's get ready to rumble
Get the reeflings remove their tentacle at once. No, we can do it. I need the tentacle
We gotta work on gen two
So all of your throw up she's back. Oh, no
Oh, no
Guess who's back back back back again skin skin
Stony's back back back tell a friend friend friend. Yes. He's back. Yes. She's back. Yes. He's back. Yes. She's back
Wow
I created a monster because nobody wants to see
She's chopped liver and I'm back na na na na na na na down down
I don't know the words. I just know the kind of tuning and what meant to do
Um to take a cog
Okay, there's a cog over here. I'm getting the cogs cogee cogee cogee
It's running in
This looks like a job for me. So everybody
Just follow me because we need a little controversy because it feels so empty without me
And this looks like on top for me. So everybody
told me
Look at that piece so empty
I hear it
There you go. Fuck
No
Can someone help that refling? What you help that refling?
Ugh
Will youtube get mad at you for singing? Yeah
Oh, you're gonna protect me. Yeah, you're gonna protect me so hard. Yeah, you're gonna protect all over me. Fuck you, bitch
Sorry, I threw the cog
I'm going up the stairs up the up the stairs
This looks like a job for me. So everybody just ink on me because we need a little controversy because if you're so
Empty with that
Start the rope way. Yes
That can you pull that?
What
And they realize if there's a blight former
Uh, right one parish
Take this blunt damage. Jeez. Oops
Nope, that's friendly. Nope, that's not friendly
Nope, that's friendly. Oh, that's not I'm getting spanked about
This feels so empty without ink on me
No, no, no
We should uh, I need to hurry up and come out with my parody songs. I wrote so many before debut and I've not done one singular one yet
I usually come out and do it need some stalling
Stop stalling and actually do work
I've been sitting on two lovers for ages. I want to do a cover a Scottish cover of two lovers
Two lovers forbidden. They want another
And they're only wishes to be together
I didn't realize I was gonna fall for what
I didn't realize
He's so on fire because you're feeling hot hot hot
So anyway, all you do is work between your shuman sketch on your constant. Thank you guys. There's no stalling
any halloween fun
you
I mean
Maybe ASMR halloween if you want like vampire
And like ghost girl type halloween like ASMR roleplays
We could do that
Shawnee we're the two lovers
Forbidden from one another
Management debated our people
Adam and a year of pregnancy stole us apart
But then we could be together
Secret don't know
Ow
Lyrics coming at you. It's super strong. Oh, whoa. Whoa. Whoa. I can't see the enemy. I literally cannot see the the witch
I'm sorry beefling. I can't see him
Where is he?
I can't he's coming for me. I literally can't see him in the winter wonderland for
I don't know
Vampires Shawnee is one way to get some iron. Oh, oh, that would make sense
Oh, oh my god vampire girlfriend needs iron ASMR
Oh, but youtube is youtube
I'm not sure what's going on at youtube headquarters. Um, I saw three
Channels either get a warning or video removed. Um, one had kissing in it. Oh, I've been gang. I've been ganged up on
She stand up shape up
Um, have I bit off more than I can chew?
I think I bit off more than I can chew
I'm biting off a lot more than I can chew right now, but that's okay
surely
Whoa, that wasn't me. Who the hey, what?
I assure you that was not me
Have I gone the completely wrong way? I think I have
I've gone completely wrong way. Hold on reeflings. I'm coming to join the party. I'm sorry. I went on a quest
I
What do the youtube overlords have against these one it's just really frustrating because they've not come out
Wait, how are you there? What?
It's just frustrating because I've not come out and been like, yes, we have changed the policy
This is not allowed now
Instead, it's just like no
We're just going to give everyone warnings and bans and timeouts and xyz lmno p and it's like bro
Just fucking say it. Just fucking say what you've done. Like you've changed the policies obviously
Um, I don't know why you're pretending you've not because everyone's getting warnings for shit. That was like fine months before
One of my oh, she's moved all to membership and she's still got a yellow. Oh, yeah
No, I get yellow on my a live stream on my membership streams, but I'm pretty outrageous on my membership streams versus like
This stuff
It doesn't matter to youtube the ai will get you and
What it is is the ai that transcribes videos like, you know that thing that literally is like, oh, this is what this person's saying
Oh, this is what that person's saying
and
that's basically how the
Determine if the video is bad enough to put limited ads on
So you need to like space out your swears. You need to space out or you can just straight up like
Swap out words like that's why we say ink
because
There's nothing wrong with the word ink. There's nothing wrong with it. Oh
Okay, we do good. Um
Or just be Scottish. Yeah, I seem to get away with a lot more than everyone else because I'm like, um
I do not get as much of limited ads as they do
Um, they all seem to be mega unlucky and I genuinely think it's because it kind of keep up with what I'm
Seeing half the time
Uh ai enforce corporate sense. Yeah, so when um, like emmy got done
It's an ai that did this the rat. Whoa. Whoa. I was speaking of rats. Um, the ai sniffing
It didn't they didn't care that it was a pet rat
and because the ai identified it
The youtube chose the ai side over being like this is literally a pet rat sniffing a microphone
We don't know what to tell you
Um, and like youtube chose the ai over like actually having a human review it and it's just they've obviously
implemented something and it's just absolutely
Just pish and you know, it's causing absolute bedlam for asmr
But obviously but that's the thing. Um asmr is like the fourth most searched
um
Like category on youtube and I think that's my only like this is just a hundred percent my bias
Of like they don't want to publicly say that they're limit in it or discouraging creators from doing it type thing
but
They are and I think they mean they don't want any of the the flak of it
And that's why they're just keeping it hush hush and like just delivering warnings like
Um, you saw seafoam come in recently
Well, per seafoam had to like fucking delete a shit ton of videos
And she shows her face while making the videos as well. So it's not like audio content
They can't just be like this is audio content meant for
It's like no like this creator is just
freaking like and there you want to know the extra extra annoying thing
And what the fuck is going on? What did we do?
Um
I will have
Um, what was the thing before I got distracted by the game? Sorry. I'm enjoying the campaign. I have to admit I really do
I like the story of this. I like the story of it
I
Don't want to put effort and resources into actually reviewing this. Yes. Now. I do come pretty. I completely
Comprehend that there is far too much content that gets uploaded to youtube on a daily basis
There's far too much the servers blah blah blah. It's not even profitable
However, if you're going to grant monetization and they've lowered the monetization requirements as well
Um
Oh, you oh, thank you reflin. I was gonna
Okay, I think um
Like wait, what was the same kind of cute string of sentence together
a
Cheek up audio. Hmm. I heard about her play
That's what I'm saying like
If you're gonna lower the monetization so even more channels are monetized. So you're encouraging
People to be like more content if
Okay, this part is bastardo
monga
Hey, oh my god, it's good. Uh
What your character looks so fucked up. I'm not even he only has one eye
Jesus whoa
I'm afraid a small deception was necessary
Yeah
Cameo baggage
Play does all for saps, didn't she?
The village of toxtad
Avail to conceal my tower nothing more
And now my home has been stolen all the same
Um
To unmake this storm then reclaim it flame must be carried to the urns
For the rich in the beginning. We must accomplish this before she knows they're here. So be sure
What
Okay, I dropped the torch. You'll never believe it, but I dropped the torch already
It was my only eject. It was the whole the torch and I already fail
Okay, where am I to go?
Where
Uh
No, no, no stop. Okay, what this way
I'm coming. I'm coming
Oh e for ignite sorry
Okay, we're we're we're doing stuff
Okay
My old stress my old story wait, I don't have the torch anymore
I don't know who has the torch do we need to get the torch off of her I put the torch in the pot, but now I don't have a torch
I'm getting fucking sucked. Oh get off of me
Whoa, I have a bomb I'm bomb bomb bomb bomb
I
I'm focused back at it
No, he's puking on me. He's a pukling. No
Pukling you didn't deserve
I'm the olympic person
Oh come on be a little bit faster
All right, so the charge just responds right I'm protecting protecting protecting. I'm swinging
There's no
I won't protect
No, it's funny sharing she has a bomb when my speaker's right
He's overly humiliated
Please give another torch
Please give another torch lady
Oh the grand is very interesting under the whoopsies stop it
Where's the torch? I don't see it. Has reflin already got it?
He's got torch no one got torch lady give us torch
How do we get it?
What are you doing? You're not even helping the dang fey. You're just twiddling your fingers around lady. Am I going crazy?
She's just my been literally watching as the old art work for her
Oh, you got it you got it you got it good good good good good get a good good drum job
I gotta go. Thanks for the stream. Thank you reflin. Yes. I make soup
So I'll take all the chicken off that I need and then I make this
And then if it's really good, I can freeze it and then I can have super healthy meals all the time
Uh, there's a big baddie
But
Hey, no only I'm a lot of stun lucky
I believe him to death
Okay, we speak to the lady
Hi lady. Did we do what you need to did we save your turn?
Hi
Whoa, what?
I'm a japanese curry. Coco curry
Itadakimasu
Oh, what's going on?
All right
Oh, she's tired to the tower while we may
Okay onwards to the tower
Going to the tower
Rest the well
Rest well to those who need to rest
and
I think the stream still got another three hours
And we'll redirect
Rats come burrowing in through my waist cutting rats. Who you calling?
What are you up to now? Oh wait? Are we hurting her sister?
Oh whoopsies
I don't want to hurt your sister, but if she stands in her way of like, you know living
Indeed that was sienna's twin uh-huh some necromanic horror
Uh-huh
Oh, we did the first part of her story wait, where's other
Oh
Oh, we did it
trial of treachery
Why did I call us free?
Thank you treasure seekers. I don't know why I called us treasure seekers
And there wasn't anything related to the plot
A sheepster's streaming okay for any harem that might be lurking in the shadows or anyone who is
Not quite looking for a vermin tide experience
Please do not worry for my gen mate sheevy cotton bump link below
Is streaming right now?
What
I've got a box. I'm not really bothered about the tomes. Ah, I got the most melee kills and the most headshot
I don't really aim for the head. I just get really lucky
Second mission is playing the turn now. It's to defeat the evil twin. I have to go. I'll be back. Okay. See you later refund
Thank you for hanging
Okay, thank you team treasure seekers
Even though that that plot had nothing to do with treasure. I don't know why I did that but hey ho
Hey ho, that's all it is
There you go velar moderator straight big up the velar moderator given as a cheeky link and right hold on. Let's open up steam
Hey, please don't do that
What about bing bong bang bang bang?
We did it. We did it. Thank you very much treasure seekers plot was called treasure
And yeah, the plot was called
Treachery you misread as treasure the irony that I still read it wrong the first time with that sentence
That's right. I can't read and my entire job is about reading and writing
Sometimes work it work work sometimes life is funny like that
Enter the chaos
No, bye. Bye. Thank you. Reefland for carrying me
Who we got we got
daddy
We got Lenny fire
And then
If there's anyone else
Monster who you can't mom are you singing monster misumi?
Monster
Okay, we got diddy
Lenny
boy and theny and
together
You make
svana because all I freaking hear about is dzana cook zanak
I don't even know what zemente says. Oh here's xanak xanuk xanuk xanuk
Anytime I consume
Anyway into that xanak xanak dane xanak xanak xanak xanak xanak xanak xanak xanak xanak xanak xanak xanak xanak xanak xanak xanak xanak xanak
I didn't even know what it is
Monster misumi watch along you wanna I mean I've seen
We have a moderate called 1984 war friends in
Dirty dirty money
Dirty dirty money money talk dirty cash I want you dirty cash I need you
Xanax is an anti anxiety antidepressant, I believe it's
Wait, John Halo is a moderator
Hydration check
Wait, so Xanax is just
Dazzipam do try not like a string
Is it an opioid be honest?
It's an opioid, isn't it be on it. Oh my god. Check the check the fit. I love the luscious nature of it. Sorry that outfit
Oh, sorry my cable's pulling
Let's get this over with
Look at the look at the look at the fit of the roof
Complicated
Rest well sleepy heads, please don't worry if you have to go reeflands understand
Please don't and no, I know we were teasing earlier earlier. No, you are not a fake
laying or fake we fling
if
You need to rest and you need to look after yourself and you can't watch every single second of every single day that I put out content
Oh
I
Oh sugar my game's lagging concocters chamber
I finally sent my first naughty Maro to you last night. Yeah, I hope it didn't get caught by Marshmallow
And you got to read it. No, I think
I don't know if anything actually gets taken out
Like I don't have any sentence on this is so pretty to sleep. Thank you darling
reality for the
Super chat. I don't think of
We're brewing portions. I want you all to understand. I never kept prisoners here
We're bad from that one time
Oh my gosh
Is she bees witch we
Is she bees being a witch? What do I do right? Why?
Oh, we can make a potion
Oh, we made a helium draw
Sorry, I'm just so amused. Sorry. I like this kind of kill interactive stuff. Please. Apologize. Please apologize
So I'm sorry. That's what I'm trying to say
I apologize. Jeez, louis
Monka, you see this too
Um, Margarina, that's how that's how much I want you to be quivered by the time I'm finished with you. Do you understand?
I want you trembling. No sense. Oh, well, okay. No sensation in your legs. No nothing
I'm sorry moment. No
I feel bad because I missed the past couple of days because I said no don't I I'm teasing I promise I'm teasing
I absolutely fully comprehend. It is not
Oh
It's fine. No hard feelings were had. I know it's all in good fun. Also xanax is a benzo diae zepine
Also, also, thank you for having me on. Oh, thank you. But no, I enjoy streams. Thanks, Ben
Hopefully you guys can tolerate a bit of overwatch for me. I know I don't pick all the best games, okay
But I just like playing games together. It doesn't really matter what the game is as long as I can kind of be brainless and have fun
um
I I hope I don't it's not too bad. I can hear a theater
Um
We transcend into dimensional planes after them. Thank you quest for the super chat. Um, no, I as for the marshmallow
I don't think marshmallow has ever blocked anything
I don't really seem to get any
Marshmallows that are
Like speaking about
Wait, what you made of a bridge of light. How did you do that? Is there nothing here?
There's upstairs
Uh a bad game can be made right with terrible company
See, this is how I want you to present to me
Maybe keep your arm on but you need to present and your put your arms down
You don't need to hold it like that, but you need to be on your knees for me
I'm going across the bridge bridge bridge
I'm list
Oh my god, you can't create without boys got a little bracket arms
Are you gonna be okay like more
I'm getting worried you're on your own down there. You better get up here. I hear whispering. I don't want you getting grabbed
Oh, you did it
You can join via a spot. I was gonna get like a
Aim oh, I hear him
Got a rubbish aim
Okay, there we go, take me a whole second there and
I was gonna get about
Net I can and then you guys can just
Uh add me on it and then we'll play public lobbies like it'll be five of us versus five enemies
And if we win we get a round of applause with our hands
And if we lose you have to open your mouth enough spit in it
I was minding my own business, but no
No, no way and we won't say any more about it. I think that's bad. Don't you I didn't overwatch now on stage
It's a reward
Oh lord, no ranked no, no just quickly
I want to try and play Juno
Because that's the newest character. Apparently she's like Anna where she can shoot and heal at the same
Okay, there's healing
I like how they like float once like you perish them
Whoa, what is this? It's got a health bar beat up the candlestick. Fuck that candlestick up. Oh
That's right. I hate interior
Design, I hate the way that you overcharge for I don't even understand who it works. How do you charge someone for design in the house?
Just buy what you like
Do you not just go to a furniture shop and be like oh like that and then buy whatever's in the catalog or something?
I don't I don't know how that stuff works
Hee hee
Okay, we go up the stairs up
That's it
Did they not make overwatch 66? Oh, I thought it was 5v5. Whoa. What are you? Oh, we're upside down
Wait, we're upside down the world is wrong
Whoa, sorry
Oopsie
I
Just making it worse. Oh interior decorator heat out
I'm smating it. I'm smating it. I'm smating the crap over it. Everything's been smated
I send the tower
I'm trying. Oh, oh, I didn't realize
I go over
I don't know where it is, but it's coming
Just like you tonight
Oh, these items are on the ceiling. I don't know why it took me so long to realize we're upside down
I'm very special
I hear you guys we go here
Bombs, ha
Kirikou and Baptiste memes depending on my mood at least that wasn't on my pc perished. Oh my god, it nuked herself
What happened?
I think just gave up. It was like, oh, I've done it. The other two are going the right way
Surely you're calling around on the ceiling again. Whoa. I'm not allowed to creep you out from time to time
You let me play with your tentacle and all. Geez. I'm not allowed to go upside down
Man, you guys have weird rules for me
Oh
Lustrous question mark. Oh, this is like a
Uh thing
His pc perished because I had to run over watch it's overwatch that taxing
I don't know. I thought they optimized it. Well, I've not played in many a year
Well, how long when's the last time I played it?
I hope there are no swords like what year two years possibly. I don't I can't remember the timeline of overwatch
Oh, wait, I got like stun locks. I was the one that was stun locked for once not the enemy
Yeah, taxing for your mental health. Okay, that was good
Hold on. There you go. You get a laugh out of that. That was a good one taxing on your mental health
Playing over. Oh, it's like a tree that we can climb up
No secret up here
There is a secret
I'm claiming the tree like a monkey. I am free as can be
There's roots and not on the ground
And I'm getting a little turned around but that's okay because I'm in the trees
I
Make a really good monkey
I'd be so skilled at it
Stop it. I can't believe you chased us up here
go home
Blizzard did too many dumb things to make me care for any other product
Me trying to oh we can claim me trying to surprise when there's like three reeflings that want to play over watch with me
Like
It's free to play though. I do like I have a preference for games that don't cost money just because I want anyone being like
And I definitely would feel bad if you bought a game just to play with me as well and I'm like
Like is left for dead for you
No left for dead isn't for you
Neither is deep rock
I want to play the air. I want to force you to play that means the more real game
I don't know if it's gonna be any good or not. Oh, we're back in the tower
Okay, who needs to heal the most which you need to heal the most
You you need to heal the most. Yes. He'll
Chug chug chug. Hey
What over what over
So skill
Left for dead is eight quid right now. I think only Ubisoft recently did working
Blizzard in a weird statement if you buy a game don't work. Yeah
Look all I'm saying is
Uh, I have my appreciation for indie studios small studios or that kind of thing
Is it definitely going on?
Ah
Hold on. I have a bomb. I mean, uh in a video game in Minecraft
And in a video game in Minecraft
Okay, I'm pulling the levers
I'm pulling all the levers
There's two more
We're down down
Oh, I'm gonna do it what it's not no it is
Oh
Yeah, I like how they're just coughing in the cellar where they're over waiting on me. There you go. We did something hold on
I got it. It's must be
Please mr. FBI. She's just griefing in Minecraft D&D. You have D&D. No wait, that makes it worse
I like TNT so like oh no. Oh, that was lucky
Oh
You sure have an interest in texture pack the Minecraft. Look, this is just an MLG game
The shaders like sometimes the shaders might
Make your pc start a little bit but my pc can keep up with these minecraft shaders. Okay very
Very skilled
The scp games were free and have quite a lot of space to fit reefland
Yes, I'm not sure what the scp game is about but we'll give it
We'll definitely give it a shot. Maybe we'll do it in halloween because it's scary
And I'll wear my heart rate monitor, but then I feel like if I'm surrounded by
Reefland's looking after me. Maybe the game isn't so scary
If it works
What is it? Oh, it's a telescope
Telescope go on then. Let's see. Oh, it's a popper
Oh, it's gone
Sorry, I'm holding it. Sorry. I'm holding it. I'll let you do it. Sorry. Sorry. I'm holding it
Okay
Three plus four plus two plus one three seven nine one ten
Ten ten times
Ten ten death
Oh, he's pondering he's pondering the stars
Are you squinting me right now? It's not reefland time
Stream sniper, but I can still support you with reefland tax. No, you thought
You just why aren't you giving me money because you can't stream save. That's not how it works
Thank you the beauty lord for the super chat
Uh secret lab is great and it can be really fun, especially with voice chat. Um, I need to do oh
Fire no move reefling reefling. No
Reefling you could have perished bend over for a spank. Not de reefling. You could have got yourself hurt. Give me a heart attack
I'll take this
Oh
I'm getting jumped. They're jumping me. They're jumping me stop pauses
We go through the magic mirror
We do
Oh gosh, we're in another place now
Wait, did a reefland disconnect?
Wait am I going manual to be did a reefland die? Where's Danny? Why does it not say he's in here?
Zanny discarded the tomes any picked up. Where is he? He died. Did you died in game?
How did I notice this? How did I revive you?
and pictures
Set free we're not even in the same realm as you reefling
A reefland I can't save you you're you're in stratosphere
You're literally in the stratosphere
I can't save him
Reefling I can't I can't no I can't save you
I don't even
I don't know what I'm doing
I'm stuck
Oh, no, I'm not stuck at all. Sorry. Oh my gosh
Uh, uh, I don't know where they go and all turns around and topsy turvy
I don't understand what's going on, but I think we're doing okay. He went to a better place
Okay, I find I find the reason we will get you
Hello friends, are we doing today? We're good. We're doing stream sniping
We're finishing the base game
I'm currently master debating on getting
The dlc or not
But I accidentally advertised us
Uh, yes, I pulled the lever
What did that do did they do anything?
Hmm, I mean, okay, okay
Oh, this is dlc. Wait, how am I playing dlc?
Hey, this is dlc
Let's hope it worked quick
I repeat that and tell me face. Oh, wait, it is. He's a good reflin. He's got where he goes for all the good reflins. So
Uh
I don't know what I'm doing with this
I'm just bringing it anyway. I'm just happy to be here. I'm just following you. I'm just following you
Uh
You're destroying the alcohol. Why would you do that?
How else am I gonna
That don't say those things that look that's not you're not supposed to say that's what I meant to do
Why am I walking around with a gargoyle's head?
This is free dlc. Oh, did they end up changing it?
Okay
Leave him alone
I'm following you. I don't know if you know where I go
Uh
No, what you're pointing you're pointing
What does that mean you're pointing go that way? I don't know
What what does it say all heroes must be present
Not a reflin like me with someplace else the milking chamber
Crune
They really said focus focus is that that cannot be the
Okay, protect the reflin protect the reflin protecting replay. I am protecting and loving and thinking
I
Thank you
Pick up the barrel. Yes. Do we need this gargoyle head? I'm starting to think we don't because we have taken it across quite
a lot of
Areas now and I'm rather compelled
Leave him alone
Leave him alone leave him alone
He's my friend. Okay, so we don't actually need it
And he's your emotional support statue no refling left behind
I suppose you could it too could could be a reflin because you guys do are like all heads
You can just extend your little pentacles when you need
Uh whoops question mark
Malaysia can keep her busy. Uh, what am I to do please bow. Am I to throw it?
Okay, let's try that again
Good night res wheel. Thank you. We've been
Wishing you a good day. Yeah, always a good day when I get stream safe and do
Because I get to be selfish and not think I'm play with you
Did it work? Oh, it worked
Okay, we're to survive. Oh, oh, oh something's getting me
Something's getting me really bad. What's it? Wait, am I helping this wall?
Or did I just like walk into the enemy's street or something?
I very much like to heal myself
What the heck am I some what?
I'm sorry. I don't know what is getting me. Did I just keep moving?
Avoid the rotating skill and beam got it
Got it. Got it. Got it. Got it. Just don't be shit. Just don't be shit again
I don't know how I got healed but I do oh, did you hear me?
Oh
I don't know where the I can't even see where the witch is
You're pouring me
Come on is it still rotating are we okay?
Are you okay? Are you okay honey?
Please barrel that so dad just throw it into the vortex here all yours
Uh
Male stress male stress surely will be fine. Hope you're
Surely I wouldn't horrifically mess this up. I'm hacking and flashing and slashing and hacking
How do you even go armor you're a scalen
I
Didn't make any sense. You're not even bones. You're just like I don't know my imagination at this point
I'm getting motion sick because I have to twirl around in the circle
I get really sick on roundabout. Oh, no, I reflinked down. I repeat reflinked down
Can we have a cheeky revive? I know you're okay. Okay
No
Okay, let's do that first and get rid of you
Time for the bomba
And take your anti sickness meds to play this video game honestly
I'll take a I'll take a quick a few minutes after this one
Uh, because I unironically have been myself and sick going in circles
It's roundabouts are absolutely killer to me. Um, I cannot handle roundabouts at all in cars
They are the bane of my existence and they are the most efficient way for transport
So it kills me on the inside
Pick up the barrel we're going we're going as fast as we can
A cheeky revive? Nah revive me with em cheek. Wouldn't I not just be suffocating you?
Oh, sorry. I don't want to hit the barrel by accident
No, the rat's chasing him. Stop it
Did we do it?
Oh, we did it
She's gone
As I'm sure it will last
Well
He's going around and around and around allegedly me
My home is mine once more and Sophia defeated well past time. I returned you home
Oh, we did it
So that was originally a dlc that they charged for two levels
They charged money for two levels
I
Know I understand they get told to do that. It's just such a shame that games have to come to that
Okay, I'm gonna stand up for a moment just to recalibrate the old eyeballs
Oh
Mmm
No, I think I'm one thing. Fuck you team Xanax. I didn't get one accolade
Xanax there are two mlg
I don't know why my thumb heart is being in trouble
Oh
I'm standing up
I'm sad. I'm marching on the spot
Marchie marchie mark. I'm marching on the spot
I'm so sorry to the damn horse armor. Wait, what?
Sorry, I took all the actually clearly
I got war
A treadmill at a desk
Oh, when am I doing this on words? I was thinking of doing like a treadmill stream
But I'm not sure how fun it would be because the only thing I would capture is really my legs down
Oh, sorry. I just headbutted the microphone. If you heard that
Just feeling a bit violent. Sorry. I do. Excuse me. All right. Let me check. There's no more weathlands. Okay
Right. Thank you very much team Xanax for stealing all my accolades
And this team should have been called the the Y boys. Every name ends with Y
I mean, if you want to get technical one end is with a Y and I
Okay, thank you for playing. Thank you. Thank you. Thank you. Thank you. Thank you. Thank you. Thank you. Thank you
You're saying that the collective briefings wouldn't want to see your feet
No, mommy don't be the man
I mean, I feel like it would be a wee bit boring, but maybe I'm just being dumb dumb
Okay
Hold on. Hold on. Just checking
Ah
Mm-hmm. Hold on. Sorry
I'm sorry, that's uncapped for fuck's sake. I'm sorry. I'm like screaming at mercy. Yes, we can do that. No, I mean, yes
I
Sorry, sorry fucking
Oh, I can't believe it. I can't believe running a feature bridge. So you have to
Give me the picture copy link paste link
Move the fucking
Oh
I've not heard you speak much of your lost whole
Sorry, sorry, sorry, sorry
Sorry, sorry, fuck. I'm very lucky to be in it. Um
Hmm
Uh
Right, okay, we have to get right back into do demo. Sorry. I actually probably needed that break from my motion sickness. To be honest
And tan high layers
Hi later and together
We make hard-working girls are cute astrani gets to 450 in here. We can do it. No
Close your lips and don't say that out loud again. What are you talking about? Never heard of it
Have you and tried creasing the f o v a bit if it's making emotions like
Is that a thing?
Is wait a minute
Oh
Wait, does this have to be on you got doby tan. Yeah doby tan. That's a good name. Thank you. I'm stealing that
I mean, I came up with it myself to be tan
Yeah on six five it's low
Yeah, that will go a hundred and see what it looks like
Yeah, sure keep the changes
Sounds like a
Try again, let's do like a how about that
That's this is better, I think
Don't be tan, um
That's rather
Yeah, motion blur on a better or not
Video
Motion blur, well that probably explains about fucking everything. That's it much better not much
More
Nineties are voted for now. Oh, look at this
Are you guys good?
Why do you look like the three monkeys that are like here? No evil see no evil speak no evil
But instead it's like turning your back. You're just like no, I've had enough. He took too long
Turn on numeric ui. What does that do?
Numeric
No
Me when I see evil
It's in gameplay
Numeric
Twitch well both time limit between the fours. Wait, this is a twitch game
Are they have twitch integration
Gameplay's done. I'm not staring at it
Twitch integration, I'm gonna imagine you guys messing with me
Hudson Hudson Hudson numeric
Limit ui scaling
Enabling this option will limit the scaling of ui relative to your resolution. This will only affect players who play above
That one
This one
Or this one here
Enable these to show relevant information such as health ammo until then you met. Oh, you want that?
Why isn't that default the fun?
Oh
That's too easy. Why would that not be a default thing?
Okay, so then our other free dlc has one two three and four
Okay, so
We have another 12 reeflings that can come in if they're available
I
Sprinted halfway across the map
Just a pro game look at them. They see you hate me
Add a message from an old acquaintance up in karak asgar as
Seems the dwarfs are looking to reclaim kazid crow from the rat men
And of course it's all gone a bit wrong
I'd better send in the uber schreik five
Turns out there's more at stay here than at first glance
Okay, we're doing it
Now we must get embarrassed
Shield vermin incoming
Is he's letting me squeeze it
Right where are we going? Oh, there's like a big walkway over here
How go with the great slot there good replaying we're just
Wait, what why does a secret tunnel?
There's a secret entrance here
Or is that because I triggered some
Um
We're finishing off the vermin tight so they release some dlc public like for public access and we're just going through that
I'm not buying the actual dlc though because they're wet farts
And I don't believe in it. Um
But hardly any of us have done these levels. So we're all staggering about we're not sure what we're doing
My brother thought karellian was supposed to be irish. It happens all the time
um
I'm not really
Right
Um, sorry, I need to I need to try hard with hook right. Um
I don't
Obviously cuz I'm scottish. It's really obvious the difference to me
But I guess if you're not used to hearing like foreign accents type thing
It can be like oh what one's what but I always get called irish first before scottish
Um, it's just curious because like, you know, irelander kind of known for the way they
Anunciate on certain words like this or is the scottish are like more mumbly and the r's are a lot harsher like ghetto
it's not it's not like
girl
girl ghetto
girl like the r's are a lot harsher in anything we ever do
um
It's the way german and dutch and some are most people
Secret tunnel that's just your starfish stop it
Not much of a secret tunnel
When you can visit at any time
But yeah, you're getting a scott's lesson. Yes, we say r's a lot harsher
like if you see
Mer properly, it's actually mirror like mirror
Mirror like we say r's so harsh and we don't say t's in the middle of words. So
um
You know
Hold on
I'm helping I'm helping
Apparently I am
I can't think of any other unwritten rules about scottish
Like
The grand chasm
Not to be confused with the grand chasm
Mommy believe it must be for its own all that permission. I'm alone in let's go
And there's so many reeflands that are scarce like come on at least let me try it once and see these things
You don't have to be scared
Oh, we jump over. Okay, we just jump over
And if you want to see order order
Today we're going to pack this customer's order
And they had chicken chow mein and chaps
With a curry sauce
I will show you that I will literally download it and show you at one point. I keep forgetting to do it
because I'm just
a giver, okay
All right
It's just the vocal fries like whoa, I cannot take that on hold on a minute. Thank you reeflings
I cannot take that on
I was feeling a bit boldly. Okay
a very demure
I mean
I stopped doing it, but there's just something so satisfying about doing it like I'm not even kidding
Go and try and mimic me when I say order that way
Like literally give yourself a vocal fry when you say it like out loud. I don't care if it's cringy order
Like it's really satisfying to see it like that. Oh my god, it's a shop reefling. Oh my god reefling. What will we sell? We'll sell
Fake scotch, she doesn't cook haggis
You can spell it right haggis
Gigi oh my god, we're such gamers
Vocal fry my unbeloved
Oh my god, like take me over
And today I'm going to take the reeflings throw here
Arder
When you know when the what?
I want to go to the island. Why won't you let me go?
I suddenly steven walking
And today I'm going to go to every island
What's that?
I was on the lifelong
We're everything's island. No
Let me go to the island. I want to go
I didn't know I could do that
If you didn't know uh, steven hawkin was on the obscene flay logs
So some
Comedian was like I want to go to the island. Why won't you let me go and that's what I'm trying to make
Sorry if you didn't know the context of that. Can you shoot that? No
Um
Stony was it you that frame talking framed? Oh, I've not heard of that theory
I honestly just kind of accept. I'm like, yeah, I'm not really surprised anymore
That oh, maybe I should be more
It's like that skyroom quest give me the money now or I'll yell skeever
Help stabilize the pressure
Under pressure
Okay, I'm uh, I'm gonna stabilize the old one
I got it. I'm turning the bell
It's a price you can't
No, she's the one who voice the takes the speech. Hello, my name is runny cuddle. I have a mean humor
Push down on you push down on me. What's going on? We're pushing on each other. I'm pushing so hard right now
I think most people who hate vocal price focus on the vibrate sound and not the high pitch new part
I want to read wait what's the vocal price? Wait, hold on
Or order
Come on today
I can't do it. What my brain's trying to make it nasally and vocal price
We're gonna practice we're gonna practice customers order like what wait my brain can't comprehend making it nasally
Well, hold on I'm gonna need to hold my nose
Hi, Reefless
Okay
Yeah
You simply that meme of the moon alpha
Don't matter. Oh, I don't know that one
Stony's ai confront me. Yeah
Pre-recorded ai
can't believe it
My gameplay is definitely that of a bot. I'll agree with that statement. If that's someone you want to make
I'm not gonna argue
I'm actually not gonna argue
And after this game, I'm gonna grab a muffin
That's it. That's my sentence. I'm gonna grab a muffin. It'll literally take me like five seconds. Owie
You better relax
Whoa, whoa, whoa, I can't even make heads or tails. What's going on?
I'm just swinging
Already
John Madden
She sounds like a curse speaking spell
Okay, I'm gonna drink
What
Oh, we're friends
Hmm
She's worse than normally. She's Scottish. Anyway, sounds good. I might go for an hour nap
Leapy Reefland
I'm definitely going for a nap after this stream. Then I'll see about that. You're
I'm not gonna walk in that
I'm I'll see about that you're blowing audio. So don't be surprised if it comes
Oh
This secret
I don't want to insult it. I'm trying to stop myself from singing it too much because I'm like
I will have done is like sing through this entire stream
I don't know like I hear a word and I'm like, oh that word's in that one song
I would like to sing that one song now, but because I never know the words to anything
I'm just like mumble for like two sentences and I'm like, okay, that's me. I'm done
She says nap, but you mean recharge
I mean, I guess it's technically how no way that's the first time I've ever done that and
The
Hmm like cuz I don't sleep a full eight hours before stream, it's kind of like how I get my later hours
Fanged
The tunnels is the current objective. I mean, does this not count as being in the tunnels yet or
I'm just following the trailer enemies. I like when the games do that. That's the best game design
I don't care why no one says let's just follow the tunnel of enemy
Well, if I'm not mistaken, this looks like our location
I just chopped his arm off. I feel kind of bad. Sorry
Don't forget to bring your reefing body pillow
Oh
Should we get that? Whoa
You just teleported on my screen, I don't know if you experienced that but you did on mine
It's because she forgot to plug herself and no
I'm behaving
Where's the most part?
Wait, are we gonna have we just done a 360? No, no, this is new
Is it new?
I'm doubting myself. Have we been here before?
No, we haven't we can't have been
No
I'm over thinking
Oh
We definitely made it now
We should bash them together like the block bash and just bully one
Shall we squish in a reefland between the thighs back here? I'd be done for that
Like you already know 100% if I do get a ducky design, you're in it. Like you're literally in any of the designs
I'm not having any other way
I'm not having any other way reefling literally every step of the way
Wait for the explosive
Oh
You have blaryed him. Whoa. I thought I spoke to my my piece to leave. Let's just start
Anyway, I started swinging
That reefling in particular amen
We could also be a charming plushie and the ducky could be a reefling
Mud
What
The wait the ducky could have a reefling shaped hole in it. Wait
Oh, I thought you were making a own a whole joke. Sorry. Wait, I thought you were making an own a whole joke
Suspiciously
I'm being a dumb dumb
I
Don't think too hard about it. I was kind of sorry. Sorry. I'm a dumb ass. I thought you were making a joke about
It being in the reefland plushie and I was like, no
You're not
Oh, sorry. I just hit that. I don't know if that's gonna explode
I don't pick up the barrel and put it where
I
What
Hey
I need to go up. I need to go up. How'd I go up?
I need to go up. Hold on. Wait. I can't even find the way up
I
Am I going
Mental I can't figure which way it goes. Stop leave me alone. I'm too dumb
Like two of us can keep shooting down a hallway. Okay
I don't know where the way up is
Stony plushie with the strange whole shape didn't no, that's what you're seeing
We need to see the end of one of these
Um
Right
Oh, okay
Well, I've got one so this is progress or hey, copy them
No, no, no, no, leave me alone. Okay. No, well, okay, that worked
That was one
Okay, I'm up here
Okay, I've done my part. There's four reflins. I did one third of the work. I'll take it
I'm halting. Okay, and then this is where the other one goes. Okay, so I need to grab a barrel. Ow. Ow. Ow. Ow. Ow. Stop. Stop
I literally can't see when we do that
Okay. Yes. Yes. Yes. Go reflin. Go you can go. Oh sugar. Did that break the barrel?
Oh the barrel. Oh no, just throw it in
Okay, good and it blows up
We did it. We did it. Now what?
Another one another one another one
Okay
I heard it hissing
Yeah, I get spawn camped bitch
Shouldn't use all my ammo with that though
Uh
No, hold on
I do like
Oh, it's here. It's here. That's right. Yeah
Uh
It's here. I have it
It's a not thought but I just thought of a fun idea for a mode
Revoids carrying whenever she would say may fly. She says refling instead. Oh, that would be cute
Help me refling
Just like that off the top of my boy
Revelling
And when I'm getting grabbed by a thingy, I'm like choke. I like realize please. You're the only one that's supposed to choke me
I'm fighting the the ink right now
Can the ducky have a squeaker in it? So let me squeeze it. Oh my god. I would go crazy
If I could get a refling plushy and it had this squeaker in it, I'd go absolutely feral
And then every time oh and then oh I could do ASMR thigh squeezing
But it'd be called thigh squeezing squeaking ASMR. Oh my gosh. I would go absolutely feral if I could get that
ready
All right, okay, hold on. Let me him with a pose
And
Over here already I skipped through the bridge of shadows
We did
The refling plush better have a wiki cushion in it. No, you're not gonna be out of blending
You're not gonna be too and I'm not gonna make it too
Whenever you squeeze the plush it inks itself
You know like those party things where it goes like
Oh, sorry. That was a really bad like a party
And it comes and rolls out and then it goes
I don't know what they're called
But one of those but if I squeeze the plushy one of your tentacles gets really big
And like it unravels and ink comes out of it
Like a squeak. Are you blowing to our parties? Is that a party horn when it's like a circle and it comes out?
Wow, I wasn't useless. I did the most headshots
Silly string
GG that was a really good thing. We've got three more missions
Dun dun dun
Yeah, obviously the surrounding plush has a wiki cushion in it. Yeah
A party chamber. It must be a party horn then
I know what you're talking about but I don't want to feel squeeze the plush and it starts vomiting
Oh, that would be an alternative version
Yeah, the thing that like it unravels and it goes
You're telling us to blow a refling. No, I'm
A vomit refling when you turn it upside down it goes
Oh
One of them
Bye
Yes, I'm winning absolutely
Those rolled up paper things that sound like a flat kazoo. Yeah, are they just called party horn?
This is a party horn. Okay. I didn't realize it was called a horn. Bye. Bye moment. Bye. Bye reform
Thank you for stream sniping
Okay, I'm gonna very quickly go grab a muffin and go for a pee because I have I have
Lots of urine in my bladder right now. Okay, I'll be right back. I'll be a moment
So
You
You know what I think
Do I know what an elf thinks? No one does. I don't think you really are searching for karexon
Preposterous, you don't know what you're saying. Don't I?
You forget. I've observed your search for some time now spying. Is it?
Ah, of course. Ima would tell you that's what we do. So include
The well-earned slight by the sound of it. I don't think you're seeking anything at all
I think you're avoiding going through and if I'm right choose your next words carefully
Then you have my sympathy that is all I hope you find whatever it is you're really seeking
So
I'm eating already because I'm hungry
I was a lot of pee that came out
I
Thank you quest for the super chat early. I did like I said, I think you're
um
Tyrant sharing chair knock it off
The void is calling
Goddamn rabies
We've got
Hmm
And I can't see the rest of that name. That's those sand forks and I have a feeling
How can I tell who's in the lobby? Oh, you
Got
Okay, okay, this is called uh, this group is drawing a fox from memory clearly lasagna
Oh, is it lasagna lasagna? Is that how I'm supposed to see your name?
I'd like us don't you push that burp
Over and over. Okay. I'm uh eat some cookies to me feel
Because I'm very hungry
That magic you manifest salt spire it looks like a tingles does it tingle you speak of holy fury
For which I am but a conduit
I
Okay team name answer the question. It has a certain a lasagna. I must confess lasagna
eating
rabies
infected
Fox drawn from memory
What a name
That is our team name
Lasagna eating rabies
Infected folks drawn from memory team. Yay. I'm not rabies. I'm
I'm having chicken quespeas and I will grow muffin
And then we've just done mission of mercy. We're now doing
a grudge
A grudge served cool
Then we'll go two more missions
Oh, no
What happened? Oh, no, you came back
I said you weren't like playable. Okay, right. Hold on. Sorry. I'm just gonna make sure that's correct. Okay. That looks right
So basically Garfield Garfield doesn't have weedy
The new lore accurate story plus the actually farce only 4.99 plus s and h
Right
I don't know how this usually goes
Shipping and hostages
The s and h stands for shitting and hurling how do oh shipping and handling. Oh, okay
You know what game next finish what we started make the deaths mean something
Okay, last pretty
You
To run honey
Your plushies should have a dumpy thick cake ice Johnny has a good replaying. We're almost finished. I'm getting nervous
Oh
Everyone who's wanting to play has a chance. I don't mind replaying missions to make sure everyone gets a chance
Yeah
Okay, now I bite my muffin
I think I can get home fat. Please do not speed home though. Just take your time
The rounds take a while everything's fine
Actually some champion legend out
Oh
Are you just used to taking hostages where you're forced to listen to pregnancy tomorrow
But I'm recreating it in real life and you need to go inside right now
Oh nothing's on
I
Know to wash it down with spray and then we start the health journey today. I'm getting chicken and making soup
Where did the elf go ahead of things
Oh
I see her
You're hating on that rock. Okay. We're ready. Let's go
Can I be your muffin moment you want me to eat you?
Isn't that dangerous
Well time to put on my best. I'm going
We're in the forest
Hmm, such a bloom. You'll never guess. Well, I'm capable
The muffin man the one who lives on brulee
I
The muffin song there's a muffin song
I need all your luck in the world though for how this uh
Soup making is gonna go. So basically I need to soak lentils. I know that for a fact
I need to soak lentils so they cook properly because lentils are like so hard and dry
I don't know if you're supposed to soak them overnight though. I bloody hope not. It's not mental
Me reading the instructions on the packet of lentils
Don't mind me and my ignorance
Oh
Okay, I know that's
You just like tentacles
You need to kick rocks and suck tentacles and I'm all over rocks to kick
So
Oh, we got tome already. Have you found two tomes already? We just started the level is this level super short?
i mean spank
i like trains
I
Was watching an airplane game. It was called airport ceo
and
I watched like people that like review games to be like would I like that or would I not?
And it looked really good, but the setup took so long and I was like, oh, I don't think I can play it on stream
But it looked like a really well-rounded game. You like have an airport and you have to like put down like baggage claim and all that stuff
It's quite cute
Um, but there is a game that I found it's not out yet. It's to come out on
quarter four of this year so soon tm
and it's called
dungeon
qualler and it's a roguelite
vending machine game
Um, I know that sounds bizarre, but it's like a really good concept. I really enjoyed it and I have it planned
We'll play the only the demo is available right now. Um
But it looks really cute
So we're gonna play the demo for a stream just to enjoy and see what it's like. It looks really cute, but yeah
um
Let's go gambling on me. I don't know if we're gonna win or anything, but it just looks like a casual game
And
So I didn't question its authority. Uh, I thought it was cute
And um
Yeah, we're gonna play it like in three weeks
I'm not
Perfectly done my schedule like a lot. I didn't realize Juno was out so
Uh, Overwatch has been bumped up a little bit. I'm sorry. Please forgive me. Okay, but I did like Overwatch
So it'd be nice to play it with you. Um, and we'll see how it goes
Um, but a few things need shuffled around now this week. I'm only doing two membership streams
But I might do four next week to make up for it like as an apology and be like
Um
Trying to find like the good balance between like a two three hour game experience because then I can go on and do a
Membership yapping stream without like being
Too tired or anything like that
Because let's be honest all my membership streams are literally yapping go down mommy
Why would go down I've got all these kills so I can be first on the killboard leader because you guys always take my accolades
He
Come here. I'm coming
Oh
Maybe a good stream save game would be war thunder war thunder wait, that's a stream save game
I don't know much about war thunder. Unfortunately
I'm only reading size ago. We kicking ass
We're we're surviving until the gate
Oh
There's something throwing bombs at
That's it. Everyone's getting swung on
You
Who's that one that's throwing shit I can't see him
What do you mean his whole purpose is to stop you from seeing and hurt you I can't believe it
He's achieving his goals
Oh, thanks for saving me nothing had me choked up the fuck
Don't even ask if I can make that noise wait, we ought to push it together
No, the gurgles the death gurgle
new noises on
The bonus is oh, yeah, you get tingles you want me to do that in each ear of the microphone for 20 minutes
Team fortress too. Yeah, I think they fixed the servers in team fortress
I've never like
played it
But I would definitely play it with you. I want to be the Scottish one. I think his name is no his name's not heavy his name's
So engineer is the Scottish one
If not, I'll play the healer. Let's be honest. Oh demo man. Sorry down
Okay, we're to follow the road demo man is the first one
And then I can be annoyed that they made them have a really harsh Scottish accent instead of just a regular Scottish person
Let's keep we need to play that oil rig game. I keep over in the ravine
We'll play the oil rig game soon. Am I going the wrong way?
And the reef is under attack
Is the doctor he is a German is he a German man? Does he say uh
Can
Do it
Do it's the stain nine
Klein and do it
Yeah, Klein and do it. Nice. Nice. Do it's the stain nine
That's the best I got
Maybe you like slain rancher. I put it down on the list. I put slain rancher too
On the lit. I put it in the schedule. You're in my head replaying. How did you know I put down slain rancher too?
I can't believe it
I put down too. Should I play one?
or
It's cute. Yeah, I was gonna pretend and we'll play that with my leaflin farm because you're all cute little slains
Even if you look a little bit different, you're still a leaflin
I'm luke sahan's infants
And your head in your head
In your head
Um, I think we're gonna have to take chances
Ice makes me so nervous like this because in
Scotland like lakes and rivers and that like or no, not rivers
Rivers are moving more
Lakes in that get frozen over but there's so many stories of um folks like
Genuinely falling in and like being close to death and that I just don't trust that I would never go on a frozen lake
I then I trust it. I would have to be like sub temperatures like sub 10
Celsius or some shit like if I you know, I had a preference of stepping on it because uh, I do not trust
That stuff at all
I got it
Yeah, one is a complete game. I don't know much content about two
Uh
I'm slinging rancher. Well, all those twitter pics. We know how well you can
They some slime. Oh, that's really good. Hold on you get
You get a little laughter at that one. That was a good one. I like that one
Frozen lakes are a death trap. Yeah, that's true
I don't know if people don't like act like the ice can't just like
Do you know the shock to your system of going from
Like fine to frozen
It's like
Apparently you can actually have heart attacks going in cold enough water
And because your body has such a shock that like it can't even pump the blood properly. It's like what have you done?
I think it's this way
You know, it's good strong. He was good refland clean
I'm afraid of the water already being submerged in a frozen deep is a nightmare scenario. Literally
Did you know apparently you can't get in trouble in quicksand, but a green silo is way worse than quicksand
I'm hearing voices. Ah, ah, he got me. He got me
Okay, I might get take a little hydration
Wow
Little death by temperature shock. Yes
Hold on. I got it
Yes, he he he look at my inbox
I wonder if there's a sniper court game that would be fun
We can be elite snappers together. We we're sneaking around I can smell you
Oh
Real yard, and they need pulleys
Sorry, that was a voice line
That's the first time I've ever had a voice line uh on stream. Who is it?
But I do want to kiss in general
Okay, we got it. We got it bonk
Okay, we're aim button we're aim button. We're hacking we're slashing we're slashing we're hacking
We're playing sombra. We're playing sombra
No, it was a spawn point
I wish they would put little secrets at the end of spawn points because I always go exploring for the wrong reason
Hmm
Okay, the bomb a wagon. What do we do with it? Who?
Go bomb a wagon
No, they went through them
Her overwashed brain was kicking in already
What we have to find another path
Let me through. Why would you not make this out of wood? Why stone?
I'm spamming it, but we genuinely have to go all the way around
Round the outside round the outside
Let me add
Okay, I guess they made a path they will render. I thought we were tight. We're gonna have to backtrack
I was like, oh vermin tight don't normally make you backtrack through sections like that
But I was mistaken. I was foolish in my assumptions
How could I judge so eagerly that I what I did not know?
Wow
No game looks so fun, but I know nothing about 40k
I don't know nothing about either the refunds are telling me what it's all about
apparently it's in a different
Like alternative universe to the spacemen
And the reason why it's called warhammer 40k because it's the year 40 thousand
And that's why there's like space guns and stuff and it's so advanced. This is a bit in
um
And all that jazz
And but this universe
Is like not right. This is like way in the past, but it's not quite the same universe or something
It's very grim and dark. Yes, and there's no happy endings like literally not one happy ending
Stairs refling stairs. I say that as if I wasn't the one most um
The yeah nothing ends happy everything's like death and misery
Because I was that I was asking those who are into 40k. I'm like, oh
Like do you get excited when something new comes out and then it dawned on me if everything's depressing and sad
Like so when something new gets released you're not just like oh, that's
Like oh, I can't wait to strap in for another uh depressing storyline basically
um
40k is alternative in september a big new game is coming out. Is that so she remembered? Yeah, I listen to you
I
Like death 40k is a spin-off warhammer fantasy is the one you're playing is the main one wait
40 keys the spin-off, but it got more popular
Um, I don't break the chain on the oh
and
What's more depressing is how games workshop handles their IPs. Oh
It's not good
Thank you the beauty lord for the
Yep
Sorry, I'm getting annihilated. I need to be blocking
I need to be blocking
But I'm just taking on like a full hard myself
40k is just pure edgy darkness. No happiness
If you don't die peaceful to death you just becomes
What you swore to destroy
geez
I'm trying to like read. I'm just swinging into the void. Okay. I'm trying reading this stuff. It's not wait. What I do
That's not the flying
I don't
Okay, I'm gonna just let the refunds deal with what we're supposed to do
Make an anti-chote
Make a cheese and ham if you've got ham I had cheese and ham you'll figure
I
What are I doing?
I'm protecting this refill and I'm helping. I'm totally helping
How they keep getting swings on me that I'm not expecting
Um, right chain I'm to break a chain
Warhammer invented the term groom dart
That's what I'm saying. It's like, oh, I can't wait for this new thing to drop from the franchise
And it's just like oh another depressing plot storyline
But I'm having a cheese and a tickle over because I'm literally playing before anyone's like, oh my god, strong
Are you little here? I'm literally playing the game right now. Please relax. I'm literally playing one of their franchises
Relax
I will send you I lost the air. I will send you to the island. Oh, I found a chain. I'm helping
That keeps
I did it. I held
Now what?
Oh, we go back to the bomb wagons after all that
That was quite the same quest. I'm not gonna lie. That was quite the same quest to do that
But
I'm shadowboxing out the wazoo
Fantasy hammer has been destroyed by GW almost
Two decades now end times you're playing now is the tail end of it
They are bringing it back due to pc game popularity. Yes
Pull the lever Frank. Ow the door just collapsed on me
I
Am the bone wagon
That's why they have the orc orc is the comedy really
Grimdark world didn't exist before war hammer for a key. It looks like clary is the word
I'd like to play
Total war hammer is really carrying fantasy
Oh
I mean, I thought this was a well-made game, but maybe this is like their only well-made game
What now
Oh, we ignite it run away replays, but we can still oh skip shit. Okay. That's scary
So I might throw if you heard that it got frog in my foot. Can we see it from here? I hope we're out safe this time
That was it
Where's the bridge
I
It's over here
Stand up shut up
Kind of anti-climactic it literally it's like get out of there 20 seconds to run away
Maybe my
Okay, we did it we did it we did it what's that three more
He's throwing he's throwing you throw I just had to be a frog. Oh, yeah, you want to be the frog I'm after arena
We're getting there
Orcs literally our funk is he thinks from your heart enough makes him do other worldly stuff
Me for real for real
Let me be your frog
Remember the time to play sonic heroes and then I go tell them
Escape through the bridge of shadows we did it
Okay, yes, okay, we made it we made it
I'll be the butterflies in your stomach. Oh, that's pretty good
I need a round of applause
Why didn't juji thank you team lasagna eating rabies infected fox drawn from memory
Yay
That reminds me of a joke a question rather what did Cinderella see
Stop that's all right. All right. Go on then go on then
Reflings what did Cinderella see when she got to the ball?
Anyone anyone at all are you not sure
A classic if you will
Yeah
Time to put a stitch she gags she too. Yep. Yeah, yeah, you putting two and two together
headshot
Uh get it because she Cinderella got to the ball
Dang, I just joined and got gawk gawked on site
Are you squidding me right now?
Made a bet that I'd give you $50 and sub if you could put me under during one of your asmr streams
It's never happened before so surely this was a safe bet. Here's your $50
I
Made a bet that what
Pika only thank you. We've what made a bet that I'd give you 50
And subscribe if you could put me under during one of your asmr streams
Damn really
I think it means the hypnosis one
Thank you
Hopefully I can do you justice this week because I've got to forget your name one
But I'm going to try and make it really comforting and reassuring
Man both one and lost real answer
Real answer
Mummy's gambling behind her pants
Yeah, thank you again Pika Ollie. I didn't expect that but yes, um
Maybe yes, uh, I I'm doing I forget your name
The joke is better when preform through action not words
Thank you the booty
What's my name again? What's my name? No, it's going to be a comfort and like
Um, you're going to take on the name of reefing and what reefing means to me
Like I'm going to make it really lovey-dovey in terms of like
reefing to me means like
A source of love like a source of comfort a source of accepting and like we both want to do it towards each other
Um and offer that towards each other like that's what I'm going to try and angle the hypnosis to
My only concern is that it's not going to be too long
That's my only concern. But as I said any, um
Like ASMR script
um
Sorry, uh, any
Hypnosis streams will be turned into like full-blown role plays. So you could so there's no like
Having to deal with any mistakes errors or things that I've said that weren't quite on par with the script
Um, I will make them actual videos
I was Johnny's favorite weapon the glock glock 19
She's gonna make me have an identity crisis. No, no, no, no, it's only temporary you only forget your name until I'm done with you
I I it's even if it doesn't like bring you back if that makes sense like I'm
Setting it so you will like go. I'll come back into those. I'm not making it long at all
My name for refling, of course
and
But hear me out. What if I don't want to remember? Oh, but that's your identity your name. That's who you are
She's gonna make me have a temporary identity crisis
Career
I've not played any other character. I might I'm maybe the fire lady. I might want to play
But if I've swapped to her I assume I lose everything wait wait
Overcharge increases spell charge up increase range damage
Fire walk teleport after not casting spell do sure. Why not? I'll try a new hero
So what
Is the magic like unlimited
Is the magic unlimited is there any reflins who are wanting a spot that hasn't had a shot yet? I think maybe you'll
But when I've won
Are you squidding me right now
My name is my name is my name is John Cena
If the bar goes fully hurt myself
Wait that doesn't hurt me
That doesn't or can I not it would that hurt me in game. Thank you the booty lord. Thank john Cena
Internet basil fail. Thank you chat. It's like you're using the shared brain cell. I mean
something
It does be don't see you you're on fire
I cast fireball
What's that dungeon master? I'm in an enclosed area. I cast fireball
Mama, I know your tricks
You said the effects only last until you're done with us
But the truth is that you're never done with us or therefore all hypno streams are permanent
Whether we remember or not
I would not do anything
Uh
Everything that I wonder
Are you you're in the prologue refling
You're in the pro role pro role. Why are you playing like that prologue? You've not played this game before refling
I don't want you to force the play it
I mean
You you could just kind of you could okay this reflin hasn't had a shot
Is there any reflings that want to stake a claim that they've not played with me?
um
All right, I'm sorry. Let me just judge your games it fall out new vegas. Okay shapes two
What shapes two? Sorry. I need to judge this refling immediately
shapes two what game are you playing?
Oh
That game, okay, do you not think you should work to control your
I want to have a shot but now that
I hate that I played this game most on a sports and forgot all characters
Mayflies death to all except their own eagles if there's no new we fling then
Oh unless
Okay, there we go. Got it. We got a team. Yes. I think that's all the reflings now
That wanted to play which honestly maybe works out
Better because I was actually worried I was gonna run out but as I said we are stream sniping during the week
Which helps
I know for you
We have a decent thingy
Are you telling them to leave? Who to leave? No one
No way you're new to this game
Reef fling are you why would you buy this game because of me your level one?
Reef
No reflin are you
Maybe you've played it before
At least it was on sale reflin. Do you even know what you're gonna do?
I don't know. He's hopefully you've played before
He's smurfing
Got to play with mommy it's worth
Uh, okay swing with mouse one and then you block
Oh
This is gonna be into
Your level isn't high enough for me. Here's some more
Oh, you played on xbox before. Oh, okay. Okay. Okay. Okay. Got it. Got it. Got it. Got it. Got it
Oh, no
What happened? I'm the host. What do you mean broken connection? It's my connection
Am I still online?
Huh
Have I been banned banned for getting carry am I still online?
Wait steam just broke. No, don't know when I'm streaming. Are you serious?
Wait, no, it's offline. Are you serious? We're almost
Been it. Wait, how long does it go down for? Can I stall? How long am I allowed to stall for? How long does it take?
Is it like 15 minutes or like Tuesday's a maintenance date not long
A while
At only a few minutes
Uh, this everyone
No
My work break is over. Please give me energy to last the shift mum. Oh, I send you all my energy
You can do it replaying. I believe in you
Come gambate gambate refling. That's right. You're getting Japanese
Scottish Japanese motivation gambate do your best to refling
Thank you housekeeper. This is for
Google says less than an
Everyone
I'm Edward
I could make a deal
Hmm
Damn bathy
I'll read some marshmallows and we'll try if it doesn't work
What we'll do is we'll wrap up fermentation very quickly in another stream. What am I doing for the rest of the week?
I know i'm doing black ops one
I can't believe that oh we're doing tavern master tomorrow, which is really short
Maybe on the peggle stream pegs all over you. Um
Yeah
Thor man do all my energy
And she has eyes bigger than a panda
I like I don't get all the secret world tavern master into vermin side
The last two maintenance six ten minutes
I'll read
Marshmallows to the dramatic vermin tide audio in the background. Okay
I can't believe I picked maintenance day. How could I have no thought about that?
Stream broke mommy. I kiss you make you feel better. Look, I can't believe I was so dumb
Um
I refling and chat said not to tell you so
Here is the story of
Nickle the bomb grog. It's important to know the grots are like
Tiny weak pathetic cowardly orcs and they get abused and treated like garbage by the orcs and forced to do all the tedious and meaningless work
Sometimes they're killed or eaten for no reason orcs only respect strength and size and scaling combat
They live for war and their idea of fun is a good scrap
and
Slid the last few meters to the fuel tank and crawled underneath as rounds pinged off the metal above them
He proceeded exactly as the boss had told him planted the wiry thing press the big red button and wait until the tickly
Oh the ticking stops
He couldn't help but smile to himself at job well done
Maybe when he got back to base the boys would finally be nice, but he nuked himself
And he didn't know
Oh
He nuked himself and he didn't realize all he wanted to do is be accepted for a little guy
Oh munching on strony's pheromone maxed moth. No, don't type that refling. What was that? Don't make me read that
Don't make me read that
um
Literally, you know
a
Uh
The grimest of all the grim
One thing about the orcs is that for them seeing each other explode is peak comedy
Hmm. I know it's Tuesday. I know
I'm gonna I'm gonna see if I can stall enough for the servers to boot back online so we can finish
um
That's annoying
You have made my life better with your bubbly energy and your asmr
The asmr has helped me get to sleep watching your students and boys have helped me get back into a better headspace
Keep doing what you're doing. Much love and appreciation. Ah much love too, reethlin
I'm glad you can enjoy it. It's
It's really nice people being like, oh I'll get a lot out of your content. I'm like, I'm just being me. What the heck?
I'm you're doing my thing, but I'm glad you can get a lot out of it because
It is just fucking gibberish half the time like honestly like
If you want to boil it down, I just come out with anaheem and everhin
Don't make no sense
But maybe that's the fun part
For some reason
I
Have it's marshmallow different from chat. Just curious as to how you feel about
Oh marshmallow is people like anonymously can type what they're thinking whereas chat some people feel a bit like
Oh, she can see me. I'm embarrassed and I don't want to type and like I know there's also a lot of like lurking reeflings
That don't like typing and I don't want them to feel like forced. I'm like one of those shimmers that are like, oh my god
You've not typed anything
Like I don't know what you're complaining about if someone just wants to chill in the background. Let them chill. Jeez
Jeez
She's making it all up on the fly. She has no idea. No, I don't and it's going well
Um, you're in my chat and not talking to me. She won't she's shadow box and shadows get
Guys she has a gun to my head. She's forcing me to type
Chat reeflings. I'm h word
On main h word on main
The sequel to the pregnancy video doesn't have to be childbirthy silly sausage. Hey wait, I say silly sausage
It could just be something sweet
Like singing lullabies to put a newborn asleep with some more positive affirmations or maybe you can bath and clean us
I just need more mommy's Johnny
Honestly, the bathing one's really cute. I think that's adorable
Because it would have nice water sounds in it and like bubble sounds and stuff
Oh, that's cute
Oh, it's quite Disney. Oh, no. I might just have to do that. Oh, you've done it now
Hey, Johnny, your brain was infecting me because I've started to say real and true. Oh, I need to stop it
Oh, that was a big yawn
Did you sleep well?
Are you tossing and turning?
You've been tossing and turning a lot in your sleep, baby
Okay
You've got a stinky nappy. Okay time to put you in the bath
Where did real and true come from? And there's this really famous twitch clip
And the guy was on cocaine. Are you squidding me right now? Sorry. I don't know why that's I mean it came in
Then you have reeflings like me who say the most out of pocket stuff mods come at me
No, my mods are good
They're or asking the girls like what do you want from your mods just in case they're missing
Um, and obviously I got asked to because it was management that was handling it
And it was like do you have any notes for your mods? And I'm like, no
mods are fine
They get my level of humor they get that you can get away with a lot more in my chat than the average like streamer would get away with
The mods got them. Wait
Oh
The but hey lord, thank you for the super chat
But I mean you did dare the mods to be fair and you know
And the mods challenging
I started saying she vala, which literally means who goes there after a burp
she vala
Mods nah had win. Oh fuck with the boy
I assume it was a timeout not a pair of my band, right? Sure one couple 10 10 seconds
Release my boy. He didn't do anything. I'm worthy sacrifice. What are you gonna do ink me? Yes. In fact, I will
Why did the mods lurk? Oh the mods aren't to talk
They've been silenced mods don't talk the only time mods talk is to link when another girl goes live
Hey another video girl go live
That's why like if there's a miss input on a mods message they delete it instantly
Because they're not to talk because
As they should
And they do it for free. They do
Key vala. Sorry English then are a bit the same
Key vala
Who goes there? It's back online. Oh my god. I stalled enough
Reflang did you prank me?
Oh
Oh, hold on a minute. You didn't prank me. Hold on a minute. Hold on a minute. We're getting there
Oh my god, it says I'm in beach trip studio. I can't believe it. I can't believe you just found out I'm in beach trip studio. Oh
Okay, okay. Now originally the team was made of peppermint dot gar and lany boy
No, I'm not being advertised so go away already. I'm locked the DLC apparently
If anyone has a claim
Uh
Then lany you're being substituted not prostitute substituted and
No, the advert is literally in-game advert and I sat and watched it thinking oh
I started I had an interesting idea for something but I forgot what it was because I was half asleep and I forgot to make a
No, I'll just say that. I love you. That's funny is anything
Someone sent me
Someone sent me I I'm smitten and that's it and it's a photo
I'm on choirs. Oh, it's me. Oh, it's my thumbnail
Muds love you too, mommy. Oh
Hey
Oh
God going through your vods with some
With some errors that I missed and you say certain phrases that triggers my I love you
And I need to comfort your response and I alt tab to the void and try to type a supportive message
But it's just the void not live. Why I'm so cute. Oh, are you trying to comfort me in the past? I promise everything's okay. I'm having a good time
Oh
Mommy's pimping out a reform
We are dj's here. We openly tell strony who wanted to artwork us. I mean, you know
It's showing yourself in vitro for sure. Oh, I can't believe I'm being I'm being dogs live
I am in vitro. You mean what's going on here? Oh, my goodness. Yeah
My stream my steam level zero. That's how
What impossible to unfriend refling
Um, you already
You already see that you're a bit more energetic with some
Older streams on her. Wait. I'm more energetic now
I feel like the the exhaustion hadn't hit on the older streams yet
Stream steam level zero pathetic. Don't laugh at my zero
my zero interest
Okay, is it working? Okay, you were oh, no, you can't come in. Why not?
I can invite you to watch have it that you can watch a stream within a stream
Maybe reboot the game I think I'm gonna have to
Hmm
Hold on. Let me do that and then let me go vermin tide and let me open up vermin tide again
Uh-huh
And then we open up vermin tide
I
Have to restart it open beta get out of here
Stop advertising to me when I'm trying to play a freaking game that I've already paid for enough with the advertisements
Anyway, now that we've established we hate advertisements. Did you know I have five lovely gen mates all of the uh
Fantastic streams differentiation. If you like a yapper, you know
Okay, it's a fishy what the heck
Okay, bloody bloody blah read before playing a very small percentage epileptic seizures
I feel like if you have to put epileptic seizure
I've uh, I know that's rather
The first thing you know loading
Loading start game adventure
Okay
No, no, don't advertise me
Don't care
Okay, I'm gonna try the fire lady because I ain't really mucked about with her yet
Can't let them know you score 20 10% off your gamer sub
Yeah, or any of the girls in that matter because we might be able to get a cup
And I will be doing terrible things to that cup in a photo shoot
And I'm not even gonna pretend otherwise because uh gamer subs is actually super cool and awesome and they don't care
And uh, they're like yep as long as you advertise it knock yourself out and I like oh, okay
Uh, I'll be putting that cup in between my cheeks lickety split that's awesome
Mm-hmm
Cup is going spelunking. Oh, I think it's too big
That will become see I can do it with my butt cheeks
Sheebie will do it with her boobas
And then we'll combine the photos together
And then it'll be perfect
That cup
I mean your tearless said that you like to be straight. How dare you bring that out?
I told that to you in confidence
You don't have to unlock suction or auction off the cups
Put the shaker between your cheeks and mix your drink by shaking your butt
If only if it worked like that, you already know I would do that. I'd be sorry. What are we talking about?
Uh, me being wildly inappropriate
Um
So gamer sups does energy drinks, but if you get like enough referrals like uh people who
like use your code
and they offer
What they call a waifu cup like your own design type thing
And I'm saying that if I did unlock the cup, I would essentially do the most inappropriate wild photo shoots with them
Breaking news gamer sups seal skyrocket after collaboration with a feature of her company
Yeah, the thug shaking
I like the way she says perfect
How do you set perfect?
perfect
I don't know how you would say it in a different accent
Use the cake to mix cake mix in a cup. I think gamer sups actual drink powder you have to mix
Yeah, yeah, yeah, you have to mix it. So I'll do it with my butt
Okay
Right, this is our original team
We are called the disconnecters because we disconnected from the freaking servers
Okay, let's get Roy into the mission
We're doing
I don't know what any of that means
I'm just happy to be here and play the game together
Gamer sups is like too late
No, she will be self-conscious of her. She says perfect
I'm not self-conscious. I'm just like did I really say that different?
But it's nice like we all have different accents than the way you see words in film
Oh a bush
Yeah
If she can make her cheeks clap when she can shake no, I won't stay in but no, I can already tell it's not going to stay in between the cheeks
I'd know more to me
Okay
Check it out. Check it out. It's the disconnection. What are you dressed off as?
You're like a
You almost look like a jester on the bottom
How unique
curious
You're so smooth max there, but this is necessary work. Yes. Yes, it's necessary
Very little of what we do falls within the definition of ordinary
Ordinary ordinary. Oh, no. Oh, it's rebecca's
Take away. That's the voice actor for the elf. It's rebecca's take away through through
After getting into ASMR I'm attracted to cute voices and accents in particular. Mmm
And me and she be were like shooting the shit a while back ago. Um
Just talking about like the like how
Like I told her everything about the process of like like why I picked everyone out
I mean, I've already said publicly why I picked everyone on that dress
Um, but she was saying like, oh, I hope we get like accent mix up if we're gonna like do gen two and I'm like, no
I'm I'm quite on the same pages. Yeah
Um, we're both like tee hee and and I'd be like, no, I've definitely down for like
Maybe a Spanish type thing. Um
Like I think she be showed her enter her a submission video
Oh shit, I just realized on this character
Oh
Wow that cooldown is like taken forever
Oh, this isn't even one shot
And when you're
Okay
Wait, it goes down so fast when you don't have to
Wait, what?
Sorry, I'm trying to figure her out. Maybe playing a new character was a good idea. Um
Mommy, I meet chili dogs. Can I have one please?
I can't do energy drink
No, no, there's it. I mean, there's the caffeine thing. No, but um, no for real if it's not your thing
You don't have to actually support me like that. Like, uh, I'm gonna make a short about how to support
your
like
Your strummer without actually handing over any money because I think a lot of people
Definitely like strongly see like if I can't hand over money. I'm not supporting. It's like, no, no, no, no
You didn't you don't see the the big big picture big picture. Look at big picture. Um, like there's so much that
even the difference of like, um
So say I put out an ASMR video and the last like five minutes are just the sleep aid
So there's no there's no audio in it
If you sat and clicked off five minutes before the video was ended
Then the statistics on that video would actually go down a bit if you stayed on for that five minutes
then
You know you make the world a difference for the algorithm and it makes it more favorable and like these are things
We're like, you know, you don't really have to do anything. Like I've uploaded a few shorts. Icy's had a few shorts recently
um, and
um
Just watching the short ones having a giggle and liking it
Like is completely free like consume that
I would say consume the content like if you aren't enjoying the streamer
You're watching anymore
Then don't feel obligated to like keep watching them like that. Obviously that goes for me
Like if you're kind of just like normally enjoying any of this like please make sure you're like enjoying what you're doing
and consuming because obviously you just want to de-stress and
Like listen to something in the background or take your mind off something for a bit and
It's just there
Yeah, sorry. I'm going on like are you trolling on?
I can beat them through the heads. I'm beating them through the heads
um
But yeah, there's like so many ways you can do stuff for free like um, I would say like clipping
Or like sharing
content in appropriate places
Is like major like I think
I don't know what's happening
Mama take a scoop of gamer subs in your mouth and I'll have water in mind
We'll mix the best energy supplement trust
I mean, I think it would work
I think it would work
But I'm not even kidding. I think it would work
Um, oh wait, I'm the magic girl. Stop
Sorry, I need to actually cast magic. I'm being silly. I can't see anything because it's blinding
Yeah, just like YouTube in general but the entertainment industry investors and people will be looking at what the audience wants
um like um
That's it
Right, I can't hurt my teammates with what I'm doing with this fire. So I'm just spraying
And then what now
I mean that went all right, I guess for a fire
I'm a freak. I dry scooped my pee workout
Yeah, I really started through that but I still said the words clearly enough. I think press r
Missing the point as usual
Oh, I can cool off
I literally opened my hands and go ah the breeze
The new monkey like souls game, uh, can you stream snipe in souls game in the monkey souls game?
If so, yes, if not press r to our word of refling. Oh shit. Oh
I got a bit overzealous. I'm sorry
Uh, I got a bit excited. I got a bit excited. Okay. I didn't realize I had like whirlwind sprint on from skyrim
Okay, I may have hit the r key so much that I also hit all the other keys around it
oopsies
Oopsies, I'll definitely be going back to my original character. I'm sorry. I'm sorry
Not the time stamp in pen as well
If present r to r word of refling was actually an option she'd spam it. I mean I literally just said she was so excited
No, I singled for it only. Oh, I'm not very good at souls games
It's why I like elden ring because I get to have you carry me around the game and get to look at all the sites together
It's like a tourist game if you think about it
You know a little tourist simulator
And you're just trying to do the look you try to get rid of the locals
And no no not the locals the ones that pickpocket you
Okay, right tug fire time
Are you squidding me right now?
Mama press teth f's in the chat box. I did also. Hi mom. I'm back. Hi missland. Did you enjoy yourself?
Uh
Wait did none of you thought
Thank you for the super chat stash power
Princess stroney look I just
I've beat your game it feels like a lot more
I don't know what the word is I don't have the vocabulary to like explain why it feels so good to like play games with you
Uh, I just feels like it's so much more
Is the word rewarding that's the best word my brain can come up with right now, but it's not like
You could carry me in outlast trials. Isn't that not a horror game?
Wait, what are we to do?
Am I are we going the right way do we just what about the other way?
The door what door there is no door
What's path of exile
The pump house that's where I live
Yes, I'm a sim strongly is my princess. Oh you call me princess. I think I've ever been called
I don't really behave like a princess. That's all
Strongly is my pimp. That's right. You're getting pimped out to the girls
Get your tentacle out right now the girls need stress relief
Thank you. Momolo
Yeah, I suck so bad with the fire
A pillow princess, okay
I mean if you don't do all the work, how are you going to see the jiggle of my butt cheeks, you know
If I'm being over
That's terrible
Terrible
We can't help it
Bonk
Bonk strong is my puppy. No. No, we're not doing that today. Yeah
You can't get me today
I'm too much of a tryhard on this game if I
I think I said this yesterday. I've lost my ability to ink again. Last time I inked
I r-worded myself for that that cheeky drop of serotonin. Um, and I've lost my
Thank you the booty lord though
And thank you. Have fun
Have fun decent. I'm sorry
Thank you for becoming a member. I appreciate it. Sorry. I don't know. That was uh, that was an internal
That was an internal thought that came out though. Thank you. Have fun for the membership. Please don't hate me
The mods wait, did the mods delete it again mods you're teasing me. You don't have to do that. You're good
Don't be a silly belly
Oh
In boy in boy in boy in boy. Yeah, I'm going back on my mean after this one
I'm just too used to the hack and slash like it's just so good. I'm I'm nuking this place
You're all coming with me. You're all coming with me. I'm not going on my own
You're all coming with me
I'm just really bad at this character. I think
Ow
No, whoa, what is this?
Idea we take the game as such powder and mix it with strontis for a moan maxing sweat
It's truly a divine mixture. No, it is not. Do you mean machu chijus or my bio?
Either way, it's horrific repair the gas pipe. Okay
We're engineers, trust me. I'm an engineer. What the heck just happened here. Trust me. I'm an engineer
Never soup gamer subs maxing. I'm following you. I'm just following you. I don't know where we're going
Thank to the prologue. I didn't realize this game was on a serious discount today
Oh
Do not I think that's a bridge
This is doesn't really feel like we're supposed to go this way. What way?
Ah, we're to go down
Down is up and up is down
Oh my god, pirates of the caravans
Strontis flavor sweaty slime
If I could get my own flavor
Possibly
Strontis juice gives more energy than any powder conceivable because it's just pure pheromones
It like hot wires your brain
So just completely take over and you let breed breed breed breed and then you're awake
What if we take powder and mummy provides drill for the liquid?
That's
Hear me out we mix the gamer subs with refling ink have a taste mama
What flavor would I mix it with?
I like when mercy was reviewing it
I think it was
The raspberry the blueberry one and she was like it tastes like blue and I'm like I love mercy so much
Is this where we came from cotton? I Joe?
Thank you the booty lord
Am I going mental
However, we to reach the beacon
Oh hold on I'm bombing them
No apparently you are. I have no idea where I'm going. Why?
Carillion says come this way
Hmm
I don't know if I want to try it
I'm gonna make
Mm-hmm content leading up to the concert agenda. Wait, is that you want me to say that because I probably will
Where is it coming from
Throw it back
It's so dramatic
Oh, I'm oh, no, sorry. I'm dumb. I'm very small brained. Okay. I need my other character back. This is awful
I need my other character back. I can't I can't keep up with this chick
I'm sure she's good if you're actually good at the game for the problem is I'm just terrible at everything. Oh, I'm literally 7 hp
Okay, yeah, I'm not playing this character ever again. I'm so sorry refunds. I can't I need
I need
Yeah, bris are bris are you dumb as pull up?
Oh
Women am I right?
Can I play the women's character? Is this the way we're supposed to go? I mean it looks like this way
Okay. Yeah, it's this way
Bonk
Mitt wait it goes right through
However, you on fire and you're like actually. Yeah, I really want to do this fight. Please don't don't be a silly sausage
Oh, I'll take this one
Holy sigma
You want a stun on them, you know the beacon? Okay, we're good. We're good. We made it. We made it
Now what now what?
Well, let's just stoke the fire wee bit here we go a little bit extra
Aim at their feet. That's how it works
Oh, I don't take any ammo. Is this not where we're supposed to go?
The variants of characters play different but you've got to play the first version again. Hmm
Okay bomb the ground feet feet
Feet feet
Okay, this is where I'm losing like all my health because I'm sourcing about
Okay, no fuck this. I'm swinging
Okay, we all need to stand on the platform any platform standards
Anyone here stand on the platform. Are we all here?
Stand on the pressure plate to light the beacon. We're all here
We fling are you on the who's missing all of us are here
Oh, there's a loading bar. Okay. Sorry. I understand you come on. Dissolate. Dissolation. It's a bad idea
Oopsie. Whoopsie. I'm a donna
We're to stand and fight on the pressure plate whilst it does its pressuring thing
I am so dead. Okay, that's it. You're all getting you
Okay, and then press R to cooldown
And then hold and then
That was very loud
Oh rare. Oh, sorry. I just did my ultimate. Uh, whoopsie. Yeah
This character ain't for me
I'm more of a swing. I'm more of a ungebungle. Let me swing kind of gamer
I don't have to think about anything
Oh
I'd always take damage when I go up to the second segment
I've never preferred for wild french though
strongy
Well, you don't like when I randomly speak french to ignite hell. Yeah
Bless it up
Oh
The beacons have been lit gondor calls for aid
That's the same
Pippin was so brave for claiming up so high
I'd be shitting my family. What's this? Oh, it's a tunnel. We go in the tunnel
Copper tarn banks
Where they all running
Hmm, you may like the dwarf but not the first specialization like two or three is very ungebungle
Oh
We did it we did it we destroyed the pirate ships
What's that? I wasn't paying attention to the name
Just doing me to be doing me
Game broke
Victorious and then we have the last one
Okay, hold on. I got a few more of the things I wanted to play
We have one last mission, but don't worry. I'll replay if someone hasn't had a chance to play
I have locked the moose. I don't want the moose get rid of it
My chair
Besiege is a short and silly
Three is pure ungebungle
You cannot say I'm not spot. Yeah, like I was literally a sandbag
Damage a little bit damage taken
I surprisingly took one three left
If you're gonna talk like a Frenchman you better kiss like one too
Why you want a glass we can kiss instead
Fun fact
A glass we can kiss right no one play the mark guy. What's his name?
Marcus crowbar. He's mine. No one play him because I'm shit at every other character
Thank you, Gigi, but let me be mark again. I ain't playing
Congrats if your name's mark by the way. I'm shitting up the bailar. Thank you for the chance
Mmm
No, I glad region kiss is not
No, I don't care if you're way better at playing him than me. I don't okay
I need him. I'm rubbish. Thank you for the game. Thank you for having me. Okay
Hey
You've not played half on
Wow, wow, wow half on me. Sorry
So any refunds who haven't had around yet? Thank you for the game. No, thank you for the game. Thanks for coming
Okay, check out the dwarf dwarven. Oh you cranking it
Check out this crank. Well, it's not much of a crank is that you've got an actual crank
half on
dash
power and
The other one tiger site. Okay, and together
Our band will be called
The school of rock real night is a really cool class for crowbar, but it does require a more tactical understanding
And have you heard of an Australian kiss it's like a french kiss, but down under
Stony is her french and or only kisses
Is that
I want to round with you, but I'm not in the game. Yeah, don't worry. We'll play another one. Don't wait. Don't wait
Okay, we will slight the mission
And right this is the last one for this story
And then we'll play to make sure everyone gets a chance to play
I'll play the first mission. Honestly the first mission is so good an ice one
Much better I have a bomb
Sorry, I got excited there to use it
Time to go. Thanks for stream. No, thanks for hanging and I appreciate lurking in the shadow
Hey, hopefully I can do a hypnosis stream justice for you
And crank an auto crank
Why did you keep loading out of that intro thing I want to see the read the sub oh there we go
Oh
No, we're shit breaks
I lurk in the shadows to watch from behind
Yes, we're all on uh, we'll watch fair warning doesn't think I've ever played this level either. I've never played either
Why you look like a coconut
This is an excellent game to play together or you like it you buy it. I'm glad
You'll be hating next week when it's over watch
I need to level up my fortnite account as well
Not against bots
I was going through the clips and someone clipped when I figured out that it was
Bots that I was against and so excited about and someone clicked when I said goku
Um, I'm gonna send it on and be like
I want them to clip the Vegeta bit as well
And you can how to say them right where to get off the beach
I'll play overwatch for you
Oh, literally you're gonna take mental HP damage
To please me you're so scared
What do you mean you don't want to play play tank roll just so I'm I can pick Juno game after game to try her out
I haven't played overwatch tours any good
Don't if you you will be taking a lot of
HP damage in real life doing that kind of thing
This is a whale
Oh, this is so much better
This is so so much better
hack and slash iron rock cave
Marie flings here, yes, Marie flings are behind me
I haven't overplayed it. All right, but I'll have to brush up for mommy
Is overwatch good? No, but mommy wants
So
Oh, we flints the sacrifices you make aren't in vain. I promise it makes me very happy that you're willing to install it for me
I'm play forced to play it
Um, I'll make a battle map
And then add everyone and then unfriend at the end type thing
Hold on hydration check and it shows I'm not hydrated and like forever
I
Okay, I finished our dreams, okay
Oh, and I went right into it
Of course the skull loves to hack and slash I just like being brainless honestly, I enjoy like
I
Find shelter
That's strange. Um, I just enjoy like not having to think I don't know. It just feels good
Bimbo arch not really but I just
I'm not having to think I press F when I think I'm in trouble
I'm slashing the rats. I'm moving next like it just feels good
And I'm like I've got the replacements with me so the game's not scary
Like just life is good, you know life is good
I'm gonna make chicken soup like I'm really excited to make chicken soup and soak my lentils because I get to buy my different kinds of lentils and just like
Life is like really fucking beautiful, you know
simple life for me
I'm brainless because you gave it to
No one to need to think is a common desire and women wait stop is it?
These gender norms have hands. Is that real?
I believe it. I'm sorry. I believe it instantly. I I don't even need to look into the field research that was done
I believe it with no questions asked
Where are you going?
Are you to go down?
Actually real. Yeah. Oh, well
I'm not questioning it
It's not it's not for me to question. Okay. I believe the research
Might send a study in maros. Oh my god really true
We should oh my god. I would love to do a study reading stream. Oh my god
We can look at independent research about really unique topics
Why haven't I done this earlier? Oh my gosh, I need to pick out
Articles that we can read and we can discuss it and we can talk. Oh my god. Yes
This is even better than the educational stream
Because it's all of it's done and we just need to discuss it and put our points together. Oh my gosh
Oh, I see a lever
I
Can't wait for her to move it to the cooking stream. She's so excited
She's planning like a bacon sprains and she can just do like
Azur being moved out just enables her to literally be like the content creator. She wants to be if that makes sense like
Just so much and I just I'm I'm nervous for the donut song
But I think she'll do great like I genuinely think she'll do great
and
We actually if her room's up I can actually attach the trailer to her donut song room. Did I go the wrong way?
Oh, you found it. No, it's an old whale's name
I can't remember Jonah in the world or something
I know Azur is gonna flourish when she has the space to yes. I 100%
100 100%
This kind of stuff is why you're more she's study reading streams. Oh, hey
Emma
I just like things
Okay, we did not need to come up here. I'm stuck
Hell free things
Oh
What are you doing were you drooling him or something?
I looked strange from my POV, but I think maybe you're just so we that I couldn't tell what you're fighting them
Whoa, whoa
Bacon a cake in the shape of our cake real Andrew Billy and the rats they deserve it
Oh
I'll make it don't think I want I'll make that plot right now
To eat people
Shania got a new pc about eight months ago and yet to put blizzard on it
And I'm gonna have to download a love you that's true true refling love if you dance
If you download for not for another one or I overwatched just the muck about me. Oh, sorry my mouse just pulled down there
He was posing. I saw that you're posing
I
Like they're just like hanging out waiting for us to show up to hack and slash. I'm like
Shape up shut up in fight like it's payday. I like that voiceline
Fight like it's PD
Oh, he doesn't get lots lots stunned when I block
Like corn on the cob
Slop on my knob. Oh, sorry, and you give me head right on the bed. I'm not sorry. I kept going
Am I going the right way?
Stop go gawping
It's gawking get all worker. It's gawking the subtitles are wrong
Wait, is it no gawking like get all worker
Is it a kid a kicking kid not a curly kid
I think I know where we need to go next. I don't know about you, but there's a suspicious looking hole
No, are you sure?
Okay, I'm not going in the hole then
I won't go in the hole now unless the refund gives me express permission
Gawking and gawping are both I've never heard of gawping before
I maybe should have bloop sugar
I don't have never heard of gawping that sounds like how you would describe a wet tucci like oh
Her tucci was gawping wet. Oh, I'm thinking of softened shit
You know, I just have really poor um grasp of the english language. Okay. I'm sorry. Please forgive me
Do forgive I am what is known as dumb
I am low IQ and I admit it
But I like it that way
I like being dumb. I like being like
This is what I believe in this is what I think
Because normally when you're dumb you have good intentions or I think you have good
I don't know
Really just try your best. Okay. I'm so lost right now. I'm not even kidding. So it's not this way
No, it definitely does not look like it's this way. I think woke on the mummy. I don't see any secret tunnel or anything
Oh my god, it's a blacksmith shop
Hmm
Mummy has to go to some real
So do you want to be a bimbo? I think I already am by accident
I was born this way. Unfortunately. I was born without the ability to correctly think but that's okay
I just try my best and hope for the best and everyone
And help where I can I think that's important if you help where you can and that's really all that matters
I
You're walking clam
Cnc moment you can you're doing with that permission?
Now that is cnc
Speaking of cnc
Oh you
Bomba bomba time bomba time. Oh, please another bomb
Uh
Wait, does he not take damage when I stand at that? Oh, he breaks through
Dinky
I'm searching the village. I'm searching the village so hard right now in between all the enemies. That's right. I'm searching and searching
I
We're going to the lighthouse and it's lighting up the way
We're self also go find a way to the upper village
We're in resident evil. We're in resident evil village
I watched some gameplay of resident evil village. I was like, maybe I judged it too harshly
Maybe I should give it a chance on stream. Nope
Nope, absolutely not a game type for me. Don't hand me a gun that doesn't like no not having it
And then I can heal a refill with this
Let's have a like she suffers from the oh you can't say that part out loud sit down sit down
We'll need remember guys her first line. We just go as her second to strong to the minute third is english
Call out any tomes or boots if you see um, I'll pick them up
Look at the reason it's working so hard to get
Bunk bunk bunk
Oh jeez, I didn't even see you
Didn't even see you there. Hello, mr. Door
Hello, there's a draw. Oh my gosh. We can run a pub. Oh my god. We're playing tavern already
Jeez, I just can't stop streaming. I just I'm already doing two different games in one day
We're playing tavern master. Look at the look how much we've extended the floor plans
Just by all the support from the reeflings getting
There's like tons of concoctions in here if anyone uses them
I'm walking across the bridge, but there's nothing over here other than a spawn point. So that's okay
Did you see the giant baby in villa? Yes
I saw a clip of this
in real life streamer
And and she was like scariman and I was like everyone in the comments like uh-huh. Oh this game's not even that scary
and I'm like
She reacted exactly how I would have reacted so
Yeah, I'm not sure about like oh this game isn't even scary shut up
People are allowed to be terrified of things, you know
It's almost like it's called like a scary horror franchise like you you activate fill whale oil barrel
I'm filling the barrel. I don't know how
I don't know what it's doing
Oh, oh, it's here. It's here refling at the front at the front here. Yeah. Yeah
What
That's not right. How is that not right? Oh, no, it's exposed
Okay, it's a specific type of barrel. Okay
Hmm curious
That game is even scarier. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. No the baby give me ptsd
On it later
Get the listing platform work
You need an unempty barrel can we just take the gunpowder out then I mean whale oil with a taste of gunpowder
There's worse things you could I mean
You know, you've dropped a lollipop on the floor before and it got all mingin and you still eat it anyways
Instead of washing it off with a five head
I don't know where these
Okay, it says already two out of three the lifting platforms are working
So i'ma just let the reflins cook because I don't know what i'm doing. I'm just hacking and slash. Oh, I don't want to follow for that
Ow, you weren't even there
It's true what they say about AI and video games if you look away they get harder
No, they get easier if you look away because they had to do it that way because it was like too hard for
and
Players like they figured I don't know how they did that. I think
I don't really know the rest
Here elf. Jeez. You really get into the role play. Yeah, that's so bright
My gamer eyes cannot handle the sunlight actually my eyes are gonna be blind and want to go outside
Well first nap then outside, but then
So normally I like gimli and v go out into the garden for 15 minutes
and
I have to be with them because gimli. Yes. I'm talking about you gimli. I'm shaming you on my stream
She insists on trying
To escape and I'm like you get fined if your stray cat gets found
But obviously she's not straight. She's my cat. She's my gimmels
um
But she insists on trying to escape and the garden's really freaking big
And I'm like we'll chase each other like you came together. They were inseparable
They were described as inseparable, but whenever they play
She plays too harshly and v go always cries and then that's when I step in and I'm like you two knock off
Honestly, I feel like an actual mummy
um
Maui gimme gimme
Outside. Yeah, there's garden
Taking bits on her story will actually go outside after her nap
I have plenty of time. It's only 9 a.m. It's only 9 a.m
So if I have a nap that'll take me to
I will actually we've got another round after this. Um, that'll take me to
What is this?
Um, that'll take me to like noon and then I just do
Walk like I'll make sure gimme and be well
I'll let them out to the toilet before I go away again and then I'll go for walkies
And then I'll get my chicken
And then I'll soak my lentils and then I will chop the veggies. I'll put music on
Oh, I'll do is I'll put tavern ambience on
So I'm making food in our tavern for running our tavern business together. I think though
And I'll chop all the veggies and wash them and oh, sorry. I was an enemy. I wasn't content. It's a tee-hee
I'm too busy talking about vegetables and
Putting
Lentils and water to soften it for my soup. Okay, you're distracting me
Actually, I need to make sure I've got enough containers for the soup because if I can freeze it
I'll be like super. I'll be so healthy because it would be really easy to heat it off as well
Fuck it out. I was a bit too brave for that
What were you to go this way over the this? Oh, it looks like
Um
Yeah, mommy's the same weeks up at 3 30. Yeah, if I have to record something
I wake up at 2 a.m. Or if I have like a collab out of the like I've got
On saturday and sunday this week my stream start at 2 o'clock, which means I actually have to get up at 1 a.m
Which is okay
Um, I won't be regular
Um
Like as I said with a icy thing icy gets to benefit if I wake up early and I don't mind doing that kind of thing for the girls
at all like
Literally it's such a small thing and like Azura starts her doughneth on
and
at that time so we can
Collab and then she can focus on the solar stuff because she's got some stuff planned like and
Uh, I wanted to like enable her to do it right away if that makes sense
And obviously when we do the golfeit collab Azura like has full
rights to like we're I
Kind of was that the way sin did it
Because since this third was stream sniping me whilst we were playing together
And when someone like donated or tipped like she was like, oh my god. Thank you for support
So I did it and I think that would be really funny if we all did that for Azura
So while we're doing golfeit if someone like denates to zura, we don't be like, oh my god
Thank you so much for supporting Azura and like and get reaching this goal like oh, we're so happy like that
I feel like that would be really nice
Um and goofy like and we'd only play golfeit for like an hour and a bit or whatever
And then Azura can you know focus on the rest of it, but I think it would be really funny doing it like that
and
Oh, they're making human soup. Lovely. Not for me. I'm the green soup. Can I go in it? Oh, you can you can hurt yourself in the soup
Speaking of soup get off me
Wait, how did you?
Okay, you can just go a little to the right
If you're back to scotland you're gonna stream. I hope you're not getting too much of uh, what's your order for it? I don't
No, no, I wouldn't change my time slot because I really uh, I think it's good to solidify a time slot
She says there's two streams right at a different time, but you know once in a blue moon
All right, uh, bomb a time bomb a time back up back up. We're bombing everything
Hmm
But yeah, sorry. No, I would keep my teams on when I'm
I'll
Obviously, I'll keep you guys up to date. That's what's happening because if I if and when it happens, um
Oh, not it
when
um
What
Bomb bar. Oh, you got it. No, oh wait
Yeah
Please stop
Wait, are we not to go through this? Oh, no, we are to go through that. Okay. I thought that I thought that was like, um
Is this not where we're supposed to put her?
You stream at the perfect time
No, I wouldn't change it
Um, I would adapt to like my sleep schedule. So I'd I guess I'd like sleep all through the day type thing
Um, because the reason I picked, um
Um
For a m is because if I have to go to the doctors or the dentist or anything like that because I was about to
Um, what round no doom. Okay. If I say this no doom reflings understood
Pinky promise no doom
I was
Getting close to going to the doctors
Because I'm a heart again
However, I have
You know realized I'm not really doing walks and I'm not eating very well
So that's probably a massive factor and the stress didn't help
But now that I really am not having a roles
Workwise like for oh for me alone
um
I'm gonna
Do my soup and my walkies and if I feel better then there's no need to go to the doctor
No, stop doom and stop don't sense that refling. Um, but I have been feeling better like, um
The audio manager is about to come into play and I don't have to think about anything after that
Literally, the only thing is hey, do you guys want ace more script for youtube? No. Okay. Well
Yeah, I'll just keep sending shorts and upload them and then you do what you do like that's it
That's it. That's all I have to do and I can completely focus on what I want to do with you guys
No, like you're my focus now meeting
And and all the content that I want to make the fun stuff the meme stuff the overnight stuff the trending stuff as well
like a trending meme always is fun for me
um
Hey
That's the kind of stuff that I want and I'll get to do it which I'm really happy about
The machine
shall run
Mummy there's only one of you please figure yourself. You worry is when you're not well
That's why I don't tell you and I'm not well. That's why I get worried and I'm like, I don't want to tell you I'm exhausted today
I don't want to say this because
I don't want you to overthink it like as I said most of the times when I complain about something
I kid you not 24 hours later it gets resolved
it's um
It just gets resolved. So like now that I've said this like I'll drink my soup my drink. Oh
Yeah, well it is a liquid
I'll have my soup. There we go. I love english. You can just get around the do you drink soup?
Do you eat soup? No, I will have my soup and I'll feel better type thing
You don't want to overthink worrying about
Yeah, like I don't want you to over worry about things. Whoa. That's a lot of words
Um, I don't want you to worry when you don't have to worry and I don't want you to worry in general
Like, you know, you're here to being chill and have a carry on
I don't want you feeling like
Was that me? I think I may wait so I need wait
Oh
Something hit me. Is this keg on fire? No, be honest
Ah, okay. Well, I killed it myself by my own. Whoa. I am low health
Fucking hell. We're getting shagged
Right, let's try this again. Come here
Okay, and then what throw it and then destroy
grab
through
No, that didn't count and we'll throw it
Like that was like that
Am I going the wrong way find the wheel oil wagon someone says this week's scrawny
I'm going the wrong way. Hold on. I think we're doing the wrong thing. I'm following the door
Um, oh fine. I guess you are a little folk jump. Come here
Oh fine. I guess you are a little folk jump. Come here
Whoa an earth is this passing
Everything's burning
Uh
I'm just going for it
Uh, uh, uh
Is there like a secret bag here
Or is it just this place is completely messed up. I'm starting to think it's just this place is completely messed up
I'm trying sorry. I don't want to lose
Okay, okay, okay, okay, we're fine. We're fine
Okay, bomba bomba random bomba
We're helpers we're helping
Everything's burning mommy has come media
Is that
I was watching a funny tiktok
Um, and it was like
This girl does like historic
Accounts of like
Um things in the past and it was like was this cat was this person beautiful or
You know, did they give her the clap for me reason type thing or something? It's like absolutely wildly outrageous. It was really funny
Um
Oh, there's barrels in here. Oh, there's health potion
Oh, sorry, I don't know you were here
And hence bunk amp, okay now push the wagon. Where's the wagon?
Little ink champ glug glug glug come that's actually really good
Bunk is that yeah, I knew it was a bad one
It's human nature to worry something people really
Yeah, you want to make sure you look after yourself
Look after yourself the way I would want you to about that. That's right. I'm guilt-tripping you into looking after yourself
What are you gonna do?
Look after yourself one last push purge the corruption
I'll be back to the star
Did we do it?
Oh, we nuked it and then we're going into it
Escape the cursed island did we eradicate them then?
Erraticate them
Oh
Well, I came up with it on my own for once so I don't know who you're complaining to
Okay, I'll work it after I pick dinner up. I'm sorry I've been neglecting them on me. Oh
Oh brother, this guy stinks
Okay, we're gonna make it off the island alive surely copium
Sick marble, how do you mean the bridge?
Ah, I'm getting epi the nap it's calling me
Oh
You want to know
You want to be nice and warm them there
You want to put on a video game review in the background
And then set a time. Oh, we're having a little bath together apparently
You want to enjoy the pleasant sensation of slowly falling asleep
Oh, wait, that was a guy there
We did it
Oh, never named us. Okay, we are the sailors sail her I hardly even know her that's her name sail
Her question mark. Hi, hard to even
Oh
Stop them in the office and I'm already sleeping
You look after yourself and we'll look after ourselves. How do you make such a deal with me?
That's a hypnosis on video I can get behind
Sailor hardly even nail her
Oh, mommy went to our word all of us really
Oh
True
I mean why wouldn't you did I win I got elite kills
I got melee kills
And I got headshots. I seem to be decent at headshots. I think it's by accident. I'm not really aiming for the
Okay, is there any reefing who haven't had a chance to play the one to play
And just scratch my head
Our word you mean like rock is to sleep, of course
And sir the Anakin and Padme
meme
Okay, let's see
If we got another lobby, we'll just play the base like the first mission like I think it's quite fun
I like the first mission
Please
I am but not in game, of course
Momo right, right
Thank you so much team uh sailor hardly even or for the easy peasy one
Gigi gigi right, let me check
Now I want to come in
I haven't had fun. I haven't had fun. I haven't had a chance to play
Okay
Pan
Thank you. Mommy gigi everyone gigi
So respect for reasons for some reasons for what the heck
um
Get pan or fish
And then if there's anyone else on the friends list, I'm gonna yarn
No, he's talking about the nap, but I think he's coming closer
Our word rubber barely to sleep exactly you raised us right literally you all have such good manners such perfect man
Rub the reefing heads. Yes. I haven't played arrived like a few minutes ago
If you want a stream snake you can
I got my steam name for a stream snake, but if you want to play if you go
Oh, you haven't played. Oh, no, don't buy the game. Don't buy the game. Just to play. No, no, no
Keep your money. I do free stream snake games. Don't buy the game. Just the
You're gonna make me yarn to the nap is coming the nap is coming
I
I'm waiting in reserve. Is there anyone having a claim that they've not played
Does anyone have a claim you already got me on it, bro, we're all going for a nap at the same time
Respectfully may we think that chief wait, what is that? No, nobody. No. Thank you for this
Um
I'm nothing to be honest. This is
Okay, the post-yap nap is
Oh, no, I'm still talking about really yawning
Wake up right hydrate hydrate hydrate
hydrate
Oh, you got you got the game. You better have the game. Yahi
Death must die. What game is that? Sorry. I'm just looking me looking for inspiration. It's just games that you guys are playing death
Must die have I ever seen gameplay of that?
Toss a coin in my hat here traveler if you wish to hear the saga of death's demise
If I hydrate before bed I'll wet myself. Oh, yeah, I just have to give you a little bit
Okay
I just went to click away
It's the middle of a match when I say
Our word means remainder to drink or war
Uh
Okay, you had the game so you can come
Okay, ah
All right
You're drained of blood you need to get blood test they take more than two vials for your blood test
Death must die is a single player rule like our feature
All right, all right. It's all right. No
I
Want to see if this all don't get in that if no one else has a claim
Then I give oh, have you played?
I'm checking my list. I don't see them on my list
Um
At least the pain of blood, why are they going to
Give me the give him his blood back. What the fuck he needs that to get a tentacle
Oh, I remember actually like oh my god, gammies twee
Okay
Mm-hmm
You just got coconut milk. I did play with you. You don't no no no not your name. You give me your birds out the
A shinglin, but you did join. Sorry. I never finished my thing
Is everyone on twitch
What
No, I'm not twitch streamer. I'm you two own
I find that
Mummy curious. What do you think of the turn beast like final fantasy or dragon quest?
the only dragon quest experience I've had is
A dragon quest then it also the starry sky
I wanted to try other things, but they didn't have like the fourth the four player system and play
um
Which I was worried about
and
Not sure you're feeling on monster hunter games. Hmm. I
I think I played monster hunter just as it came out
but
Good good gaga. I'm a baby level one
The part two to the um pregnancy is war
Um dragon quest eight was the most well received. I was surprised
You're a good shot at gaining some more information about the skit again. She's going into help and so are you
Okay, she'll be sneaky
We're going to be called team redo because we've technically done this map before the temple of sigmar
Let's allow the help would be fun to carry through monster hunter. Oh, well if you can count now, hold on a minute
Now hold on a minute if you can stream snake me and carry me through the game. So I don't have to think
Hold on a minute. I'm ready to play. I'm ready to build up right now. I'm glad to pitch in
So I need the highest level in the lobby. Oh, no
Woopie
Monster hunter is fun. Apparently new game chiller was just rolled for it today. Oh just dropped for it today
Excuse me. They go watch that right now
Enjoy
You only like to watch it if you watch when you're short, which I've already brought it's me. Oh my god
It was nice try to say to sundry and it's not it's like sundry
Oh shit sundery sundery. Yeah, okay. That sounds right
I do I still don't get how it's not called to sundry yandere
To sundery makes perfect sense in my head
I saw the shore. It's brah. I was giggling my butt off
Arista gave me and she's like, is this good? And I'm like Arista. I'm laughing my ass off. Yes. I've already spanked it up
It's so good
Um
Sundary
I mean, you can't fault my logic for being like yandere to sundary
You know
Okay, thank thank you. Thank you. I appreciate that bit
I
Just can't do it. Oh, but you
You just added a you
I couldn't bet
I know you're making me second guess. I've already been over it. Mommy say tsunami. Okay. I know tsunami and say summary
Summary summary some merry
Summary, I don't know that word
I know a tsunami is a tsunami because that's what happens when the earthquake happens over the war
Japanese both have two in susan. Where did you get the two from one to sundry?
Wait tape tape to sundry. Am I going mental on this little spell way? I think
I
Was level four in a game and had higher Europe. Uh, I know you flexing on me with your extra four
Titt right, what do you mean? Where's the sue coming from? There's literally a you between the s and the u to sundry
Say bottle of water
A bottle of water
I don't say it the way you want to hear it. You're
Sorry, hold on. I was I was being cheeky and getting up. I think
I'm being cheeky
You just said two right now
The sun sundry
No, but if you take the t into consideration, that's why I'm saying two
But obviously now we have learned that the t is not in fact in it
No, there's like a tiny pop when you sing to
Out out out
I'm getting you're getting you
T is silent. You know what else is silent you after the
Damn it. Fuck that up. Hold on. All right. Let me try again
The t is silent. You know what else is silent you after I are worried you
That was that that was a lot funnier in my head that actually came across really poorly. I'm sorry. I apologize
That came across very a lot harsher than I meant it to and I apologize if I upset anyone with that one
That was really harsh. That was a lot funnier in my head
Damn
Whoa
The
Aggressive I like it. Yeah, that was very aggressive and wildly inappropriate truly
Um
Cancel can't cancel. How can you get cancelled if it's but unless the reeflings cancel me that that's
Yeah
There's no
Like if if you want to get canned like I don't even know how you do it for me
Oh, she she had inappropriate banter with her her own community. They're comfortable with that joke
Right, okay, like what now what happens? What is one random scottish chick?
How does that affect you in any way whatsoever? Like please just leave me alone to play rampage. Thanks
Like please. I just want to play Elden Ring of the Reeflings leave me alone
What's that? Is that in or out in or out? I don't know
I don't know what that circle means. I'm just
It was like a bakery
Whoa, I'm getting stun locked by the stumps. Oh, you can just walk it dumb ass
Jumpers Garrett Garrett on twitter. Oh, no, you mean that thing I hardly use and I use it to ink and then
Oh, you got all my inking location. Oh, no
That's the threat of a boy who stormed me apply me arward. You know
Circle equals dwarf invisible area
You're stealth
You can stealth
You little stealthy thing
Starting to count for for naught. Exactly. Let's be honest. I've said worse
Right
Cancel after inappropriate joke
Maybe I'm ignorant in my way. Maybe I'm an ignoramus the door door stuck. Well, not really you can break the door if you want
The star neither will be no silence if you are you know, I'll be making lots of noises
I
Remember when I first played this I was like, oh, this is the refland room. I take you one by one
Can you we bunk beds and you'd be you'll be fighting you'll be like
No, I don't want to be on the top bunk
No, leave him alone. He's mine
He belongs to me
That's a fire that
Why are the violins getting old dramatic? It's making me nervous
Early in the morning. Have I gone have I just done a massive circle? No. No. Whoa. I am. Okay. Sorry
Hold on. Let me chug. Joke
Stop it. Ah, I hate when that happened
That was luckiest. Whoa, that's keg's gonna blue
Hello
Only I'm a little box then literally
When I finally come to the reeflings rescue and not just person about no, he belongs to me. He's my responsibility that keg
I'm about to blow
Telly who
Bastion entrant should have baked bastard
Get it. Oh, sorry. I just hit your keg. I don't know if that's on fire now
It's um, oh
It wasn't me. I was hit. It was you. It was you
Wait, I don't understand. Did we ever go against one of these before?
Why are these like unlocked now or something?
I don't ever remember going against a bio troll
like genuinely
Oh
Cause like what?
I'm gonna be not
He's vomiting on me. Oh, it's a dodge
You did it three rounds ago. No, I mean the first time I played I don't recall ever going against a bio troll. Am I just
Going mental I'm just completely forgetting. I think I might be
As a random chance. I can't myself what it is because I just don't remember going against him the first time we played together
Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa steady on
Yeah, go here with that get out of here
I'm absolutely bonked to smithereens things like bio trolls actually come more common
And oh
Beat him up beat him up beat him up beat him up reasons
It's a gas round make my way over making my way over to the gas round and really annoying me
Do
Make him always
Something's happening here. What's going on here?
I'm seeing red. I saw a lot of red there. Mm-hmm suspicious
Are you squiddin me right now?
It's random mostly, but they do have certain bosses for each area like the super dark caves from last time we played
Oh
That's random math
It's random math
Okay, let me explain. Thank you
I have a bookie
I'm so smart I read
I never told you the other books I got and I already forgot what I got
But I I looked to tell you what other books I got but I already forgot
But I did get the snowden one. I know I got the snowden one
I was looking up, um
Like what are the most like common like kind of either propaganda related
And before you're late, what do you mean propaganda? I don't mean propaganda is into propaganda eat myself into believing
I mean like ones that discuss it like enolize the all that kind of thing
um, and that snowden one was like a good one and
I'm may look into whistleblower like related ones. I wouldn't mind that
Um
I'm gonna do another George Orwell type type of
One
The e-book
Tell us Johnny. Did you get corn? No, I don't read those. I don't have an interest in like kind of either educational or like
uh, perception ones or
That kind of thing. I don't think I I wouldn't recommend like what I read just because I have a like
Rubbish taste like I'm aware that I either have a very generic level taste
Like there's no way I'm gonna read a book that hasn't been reviewed and like highly critically acclaimed type thing
Like I don't want to waste my it's not waste of time. Although is it can it be a waste of time? No, it is just chilling
and
Oh
Dear, okay, that's much better. That's much better. That's what I want to see
feeling hot
No, no, no play doctor get out of here. I will actually block for once to get you out of here
I'm swinging I'm swinging so hard right now. I have the biggest swinging
Length right now of all four of us playing together
I'm yellow up in your refund. Don't worry. It was me. It was me. See I got this kill. I helped I helped
I'm not just the anchor for my team. I'm helping
Although I'm wondering if because you guys are like all lower level because you don't have loadouts and stuff
That I'm making it hard
I
So I need to show you
Oh, you are in this
You usually prefer images or videos, I think you should animate. I think you should animate
Oh, I'm so sorry
Like content
You mean popcorn I like to consume
What are you talking about here?
Do you love this journalism?
At least me ramble forever
I always have something
So mummy gets off with education. Hey, no, no, I don't get all like that
Can you go over there? It looks like you can but I'm not risking it. I'm not actually going over there
I meant said my brain farted in the other night
Oh
I think I think audio a lot
Like
If a video has like low quality, but the audio is like crystal clear
I prefer that
over like
porky up close
type thing that's not
Nasty sir for me. Uh, oh, I'm big audio big audio
But if I if something is extremely there's a totem down in this path, but I don't have book
Uh, do we need to tell them? I don't know. We're just mucking about actually we don't need to try hard
Oh, there's art down there
Wait, what do you think?
Oh, the the art was here. Sorry, both are great, but I'll do one
Get out of here. I picked up here tons of healing. Yeah, you'll never guess what comes up next
Oh
No, the game telling me off because I healed like 8 hp so rude. I can't block him
Oh, he's too strong
Right, I'll take a med kit and then I can heal a refill and there's people down in hell
I don't have that book anymore. Does anyone take my book? Did I lose my book? No
No, I think a roofing could kill
Totems are for xp and getting better chest at them
I don't know if I'll be playing that much once we finish here
Literally, we'll go next mission for the reef ones that didn't get a chance and then I think that's uh
I think there's only three reef ones that haven't played and then I'm gonna go for a nap
But first I need to like gimme out to the heaven ship
Yeah
Because they go in the garden
I don't have to clean up any cat litter boxes because we're just more and I love them
And they're the most precious little bees
No need for video of mummies and mayors. Johnny, do you want us to send some more dozen recommend it?
We should I should rate your
wreck your
dozen
Uh on blue stream
Oh
Wow, wow, wow, wow
Whoa, whoa, whoa, hold on a minute. Hold on a minute. I ain't that fast. I ain't that quick. Sorry reef blend. I couldn't reach
My little arms they can't reach
Yeah, two of us can play that game
I use my all I given everyone temporary hk that's
I'm now desecrating corpses because uh, I'm hacking and slashing on things that are very very dead
I've got nobody
Oh that headshot I'm gonna pretend it's a headshot not because I'm on easy mode
I'm just so good. I'm just so good get right get off the stairs
No running in the hallways
Oh, I wanted to give Billy a shot. Uh, I asked my dad
If I could get the game, but he never bought me it because he didn't like it like he thought it was gonna make me a
bad
Child and he never got me
But apparently Billy's like really well rated. I don't know if it would frustrate me though
That's the only thing I don't feel like old mechanics or something, but
If you guys recommend it, I'll play Billy
Billy's the load of fun
That headshot was actually pre-recorded real and true
Jeez, I'm getting only broken
by
I can't even see the enemy
And it's like gta button skill. Oh, we've not even played gta 4
Oh, I've even thought about the gta series. Maybe we should
Gta what son Andrea
4 and 5 campaign would be pretty good. I think in
Die will ya
You
Yeah, that's so creepy the way they're crawling off
I just need to check behind me in case there's a they're paling up behind me and I don't realize but I think I'm okay
Ah, she he was gonna eat
You we did it
I think
No
Yep, ready we did it refland
My pintas it fell off
Billy is actually about fighting against them
is it
She paid so many actors who's pre-recorded rounds is actually just the same three reflings going in and out
They're just changing their steam profile pictures and names and so you've got a pillar up the ar
I see are you guys seeing the artwork grace like one of those
Yeah, look at that. No the nap is coming
I think there's one more batch of refunds that want to play and then I will throw myself away for a nap
Paid refilling us allocate. I'm not I'm not beating them. I got a chest
The spoils of war
Oh
How who
Right melee kills I got the most
And I got the most headshots again without trying. I think I must have a headshot buff on or something
The artwork. Yeah, the artwork. There's an artwork of like
I think it's of a
A chick sitting on the pier like it's anime
And style and she's sitting on the pier and it's like the pier stopper things where you tie the ships to they're like all along
And symmetrically like a part if that makes sense, but then she's sitting right where one of them should be
um
Yeah
You know what I mean? Thanks for carrying me moment. You're welcome. You're welcome
Okay, who least claimed to not have played yet
Is that an implicated? Yeah, it was like an implication because it was like right in the thing
Not bad for the first game. Yeah, good
I think I might have seen that image. I mean I might get myself
I
Okay, so any we felons that have not had a chance
To play this round
and
One are
Deus, you've not played you're not on my list
dear
And then
If you do really make sure it's really scholarship edition that is remastered. It's a lot better
I want to replicate it with a reefland
I want to make a you guys want to see a magic trick and watch this tentacle disappear
I'm rooting for you
What a a golfer that would be
Um
Check it warriors Orochi for 170 playable cat. How do you pick there's so much off like fate
fate
uh, okay, um
I think that is no if no one else is laying claim that they've not had a shot yet
Then I think repeats are allowed
I don't see anyone in chat laying claim
Oh, we're more than we're more than so hard. Hold on. I
I don't miss the march
Talk to the hand because the face ain't listening
Little little commit for let's quickly play a random mission with a bonus reward. This is the quickest way to find a party
I already got me a party a reefland
Uh, what was another good mission?
Against the grain is funny
Why not
Tentacle reappear just be reappear just be okay. I will delete my little streamsnake name
And unpin it
And then we will redirect into sheeperton as she's so up
I'm not sure if she's both or not
Um
You Scottish magician makes it disappear a little too fast. Are we ready?
Ready. Are we steady? Are we coming down the stairs?
Are we ready? Are we steady?
Because we are almost there
Are you squiddin me right now?
Today is a sad day. My tentacle died. May I bury it inside your plan mama?
That's creative
I'll give you that. You'll make a host at a little funeral. Where are you going to put the bouquet?
The flowers let you put
Thank you for the super chat the baby lord
Where do you put the before oh my god, no as with the superhero intro all four of us together. Oh my god
Oh my god, the real superhero intro right we must reclaim the reefling farm
Good luck on the mage by the way, she's stuck. Well, she doesn't suck. I suck. Okay. I'm just not good at handling
Oh my god, it's wild iris
I love when video games put in real flowers from actual really as opposed to coming up the flowers
Did you get sand stuck in your climb how else did you grow this big pretty peril?
I don't even ever heard of someone complimenting the prettiness of uh
the Doris and
That's rather funny to think about however
Hold on i'm swinging we're reclaiming the farmland
How dare you this is for reeflings only you're not reefling
Oh my goodness, I just realized the farm
Oh, no the farm is just feudalism
If you look hard enough history, he's gonna repeat itself. Oh, no the farm's just feudalism
Oh, no wait, no I can't be because I actually give you what you want and it's not like a weird thing about it
Okay, no, it's not that bad. It's not that bad. Okay. It's really not that bad
What in the cod zombies is that?
Oh
Yeah, I don't remember all these kind of enemies when we played the first time because i'm the host maybe
I'm shooting reefling. I'm so sorry. I'm shooting so hard right now
And you get yeeted. Oh, it's my turn now. It's my turn now
That's not the kind of tentacle i'm interested in get out of here spawn of chaos
Oh, i'm out of ammo. Hold on. It's hacking slash time
Now i'm beating him up. Now i'm beating him up get up drop him drop their reefling
I thought the farm is gonna be communism and also inconomy. Oh, inconomy. Oh, yes
Inconomy is what i'm gonna call it. Oh my god cheese and potatoes. Are they blighted? No, they just
They look like sweet potatoes, but not colored like this week
All right, we'll leave that intact
Call me a baby star for milk because that pro's gonna get
Okay, that's like
Flowers look our farms regrowing
We're gonna have all the pollinators visit
Get them make them regret being born
Oh, I've been
Remunda cheese
Wow, you go. Okay you go
Inconomy more like ink on me. Okay, that was good again. Well
This is this pleases me. I enjoyed that one thoroughly
Okay
I am pleased you have appeased me with your words funny man
See they say oh, oh, oh only reeflings are good for
Inking and all that. No
Reeflings also have good work
Oh
Nice running out with you. I'm good
How's the vermin Titan is going good? We're finishing up now because
We finished the un like unlocked campaign and dlc if you will
um, oh my god, um
We're just replaying so everyone gets a chance that I wanted to play and then I'm going for
And up and then I'm making chicken soup because I want to eat healthy
And I'm making batches of soup for myself so I can freeze it and then I can just heat it up
And then I need to get a baguette as well like crusty bread to have my
Because you can't have soup without crusty bread. So I'm going to get a baguette too. Actually completely
I am out of ammo. I can't help
No
That's a lot of enemies
Hold on
I'm unfortunately out of munition for any long range attack, which is a wee bit annoying, but
Go away. No, he pushed me off too
I
Was he I could hear him talking but that was too much he happened in the middle of a fight where you lost
Wrap it up or you're losing the fight. I don't know why I would pretend otherwise
Okay, okay, we can do this we're doing it. We're doing it. We're doing it
I
Are you a cock a leafy?
Wait, what's the cock a leafy? Why did I know that word?
What's the cock a leafy?
I feel like games medieval weapons
chivalry too
I love hecking vermin tight to such a good game to blow off steam also for really in handmaiden got them grippers out
Oh, yeah, we have appreciated the grippers wherever other shoes
We got the grippers up. Oh, it's a Scottish soup. Oh, right. Yeah, I knew I was gonna say I was like, why the fuck
It's okay. I'm not making cock a leafy. I'm making chicken potato and carrot and celery and chicken billy on
and
Uh, I'm using
Maybe I'll put peas in it. I do like peas
Uh, maybe there'll be another maybe cat. Do you put cabbage in soup? I don't think
That's right. I mean
I want to I want to min max on vegetables unironically to make myself super do for healthy super healthy
Oh, it's a piggy. Hi, mr. Piggy. Hi y'all. Are you just chilling? Did they leave the livestock alone?
Oh, that was some teamwork there. We almost got
Reef fling I saw rippling I saw that
Reef fling I saw that just because you have your toes out doesn't mean going to forgive you for spanking the pig
You can pick cabin soup. Okay. I may get cabbage as well because I like cabbage
Yeah
Hi piggy
Oh, no, there's not much to munch on in here. You need to go out into the field to get into the pasture
So you can get all the nice things with all the other piggies too
Damn, they did not like that farmer
Nothing hiding in here
Get for some bacon for my sip. Yeah, I said chicken
Okay
Because chicken is the best meat. I don't care what anyone says. It's not steak. It's not
Um wagyu
It's not
It's not what
Um
What other meats are there? Have you eaten kangaroo yet? No, but I fed it to my cat
The sell kangaroo
Okay, I still I'm using bomba bomba warning bomb time
Oh, he grabbed me. No, this is the wrong tentacle. Stop it
Parish
Give him
Unpopular opinion, you're wrong
Now you're allowed to argue with me on what your favorite meat is. It's just chicken just tastes so good to my taste buds
Like it literally makes me
You know, like I get our a rush of serotonin when I taste that
chicken
More more more
I love chicken. Oh, I love sip my favorite strongy fish that no what I put my feet in the freaking paw to marinate
A full pork sign one. I've not had that
Um
I eat bacon, but I'm scared of pork in general. I know I know irony irony
But I had the worst
um food poisoning with pork
Um, and it's just made me like so wary of it in general like I don't make any food that has it
Um, I don't order it
I just I've like although I say that I had food poisoning with chicken because my dad fed me uncooked chicken
Which was my fault if I'm being honest
If it's my fault
Can we blend?
Mmm
I get tonkatsu or other pork is fine, but bacon is too short
Yeah, so the oven
flame went out
and my dad
Served me uncooked chicken
But because I was such an elite gamer. I never stopped to like
I don't know. I just thought the chicken was extra juicy and I poisoned myself voluntarily
Um, and I ate raw chicken by accident
I was like chicken on the bone and I never looked down to eat like I was watching I was like playing the game
And uh, you know when it's like being a gamer you don't really stop you just eat with one hand and keep going
Um
Not sure if pumpkins are easy to come by in Australia, but you should try pumpkin soup
Oh, that sounds so cute. What meat goes in pumpkin soup?
If it's vegetarian, I
I can't have it well, I can't eat vegetarian food. That's not a problem
But I need meat in my meals because I'm I'm a weakling. I'm a sickling. Okay
I'm not very healthy. So I need meat in all my meals or
You eat raw chicken. Yeah
and
So like the outside was cooked but the inside wasn't
Like the chicken against the bone, but I ate all of it because you know, I was a pain attention. I was like
And it was marinated as well. So I think it hid the fact that it wasn't cooked properly even better
The bar
If I became like a vegetarian or a vegan like for I can't shoot the guy behind us by the way, I'm out of
I'm out of
Okay, okay. We're fine. I preemptively choke there. That was my fault. Um
I'm gonna waste this and it's on myself
Hmm, uh, you could just use pumpkins
Oh, you can like roast pumpkin and then put it in
Nice Johnny. Hi meatland
Generally pumpkin soup is only veg
Put beef in it
Ammo box drought. I keep forgetting. Sorry. I keep forgetting. I don't why I'm forgetting all of a sudden. I'm coming
Okay, I got it
If chicken is pink even on the inside do not eat it. It's not good. Yeah, I never paid attention
And I just inhaled and then I was violently ill for the next 48 hours
I have really bad history with the food poison. I get it quite often. I didn't even know you could die from it
um
I just thought it was like a sickness, but no, you're like entire body is literally like dying
And I didn't know that and I've been like food poisoning multiple times
Um
One was pork one was chicken. Um
One I don't know if it's food quite well technically. I was working in the garden for my mom
And I washed my hands
um
And I don't know but um, of course you wash your hands
I did wash my hands
And I still got sick and that was really bad
But I don't know if it counts as food poison if it's like has I picked up something from the garden if that makes sense
Um
And you say we shouldn't worry about you literally give us read. All right, sorry. I'll stop talking
I mean, I'm I'm perfectly fine with food now
but um
Yeah
Red meat couldn't
Okay to eat raw
Oh, I wouldn't eat anything raw
On purpose anyway
Like I seen in japan you can eat eggs raw because they actually don't have
that
Thing that makes out that makes the eggs like
Salmonella
Who's Sam
Salmonella, oh not that right now. Who's Sam? Um
Because they don't have
Steak tartar is just raw beef
Notice how they call it something different to not put people off of eating it. I'm curious. That's right. We're on to you
Thank you. Thank you. You're welcome. You're welcome
The chickens are taking good care of intensive food, don't they? Yeah, like in japan you can have raw eggs and I'm like
I don't know. I think maybe because obviously
You're raised that like oh raw bad
Raw egg bad and then like going somewhere where it's not it'd be like hard to wrap your head around mentally that it's not like
Feeding yourself poison or being worried like am I going to get sick later type thing like?
The only time you can eat raw I would never even voluntarily eat raw chicken
I'm gonna lie that's the thing
I
Notice all these fancy words to trick you into ordering it
I have a question. What game is this? Is it free? It is
vermin tide two
It's on sale right now
Um, but don't buy it. Just a stream snipe. This is my last round
And I'm very sleepy and I need my rest
Unfortunately my my I didn't exist. I didn't think the stream has actually been going for so long
But not in a bad way just in a I'm I'm sleepy and I'm making soup and I'm going to take a picture
My soup once it's finished and I hope it works out because if it does
It means I will have tons of healthy meals that all I have to do is microwave them in a bowl
All right. No, sorry not microwave them in a bowl. All I have to do is
Cook them like in a pot
That would be amazing
I need to go down
We'll be happy to see it
Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, there's a lot of enemies
Please have some consideration not very demure not very polite not very considerate grouping up so I can't physically see what's ahead of me
All right, I'm going up. I don't know what's up here, but I'm going up
No
Oh, no, this is the way I'm supposed to go
I'm freeing the prisoners
And all the prisoners are free
I'm talking about rogues from the shell. I think we'll take that and no problem
Yeah, why is the why is it kicked by our old something's fine?
I didn't die or get sick so I guess it's fine
You had raw for it
My nihongo chozu level isn't good enough to tell what I ate. That's hilarious
That's honestly
Hmm
The one time I ate and got food poison with that pathogen and it made even worse when I found someone's metal tooth cap. Oh
Wait, how do I get up? Sorry. Sorry. I'm reading in
Sorry, I'm stalling whoopsie
I'm coming. I'm coming lay down cover fire lay down cover fire
I'm laying down. I'm laying down. Oh, I'm blocking. I'm blocking
I'm swinging I'm swinging. I'm swinging my sword
You can eat a certain amount of cake batter, but you will eventually get sick
I got salmon on from roti my grand game one as well. She's just feeling quirky giving you something
She was like, oh, it's some chess if you're allergic to roti
Oh, she's just like a quirky little grandma gg
Imagine having food poison with a cannon ass like moment
Yeah, it's so better not to eat you can eat raw meat as long as you kill all the bacteria like for blue steak. No, oh no
Because I am a well done safe
Steak eater
There are no eggs. There are no bacteria. There are no nothing on that steak people who eat it
like blue or rare, whatever
It's okay to admit that you've got worms because you ate your steak raw, but bruh
Well done. No, don't vomit at my well done
Well, there's nothing wrong with well done steak. I will stand here
Well, I'm sitting but I will sit here and explain to you. There's nothing wrong with it. Okay
Is it this one? Okay, that's probably back
Well, yeah, well done steak, you know where it's cooked and there's no raw flesh
Yeah, yeah, I have. Yeah, I have well done steak. Yeah, I don't eat raw flesh. Yeah. Yeah. No, you yeah
Isn't dangerous to eat well done because of the high temperature produces some chemicals in it. What?
I'm not even safe to eat steak now
You did super amazing
Mommy do a quick poll on steak right now. I will what are the steak types hold on
Hold on. We must settle this. This is this is serious business. This is serious business poll
How do how do you have your steak question mark?
Answers well done
Uh rare
Medium rare
Um medium rare medium well
Uh
If I miss someone and then blue I can't even tape blue. I'll just put rare mate as well be blue
There you go
Is your poll
Yes, thank you not having well done
I'm teasing you before that
All right, don't let that actually skewer the results
No, it's skewer or do you actually have it medium rare?
That needs to redo it and make it medium rare
The right option is there now everyone is going to take medium rare are your favorite steaks
I just checked to be how well done steaks have more hcas in it when cooked
What is hc is the carcinogenic off a full steak. Can I have anything that gives me iron?
Kind of have nothing that gives me iron
I'm ending that poll
Please don't highlight that
Okay, we enjoy our steak
Medium rare
Thank you stash for for the social chat. I didn't know that well done was bad for you like that
I'm learning
Okay, let me check if she be still streaming
She be she be yeah, she be yeah, she be yeah
Drink
She be isn't but embers is so we will redirect into embers
And me and me. Yeah, and me. Yeah, and me. Yeah
Burn is bad Jimmy. Yes, we will redirect into Jim
You're gonna make me on ironically slip off and call her Jimmy at one point
I just want you guys to know that I'm blaming you for that
I'm blaming you
HCA is shorthand for eating charcoals bad for you
So we're putting black up child again. Why does that always be like
Jimmy Neutron. Okay, right. I need to hey to my screen and I'm gonna delete everyone on steam
Yeah, that's right. You're gonna delete get delete plop plop plop get delete get delete get delete
I have to open up everyone's profile in order to do it. So it takes a hot second
So if you're still online and you want to help me with this process
Uh, I'd appreciate it because it actually takes me quite a hot second to go through everyone
Um, but it's okay if you can't do it because you're not on the pc right now
Just need to give me a little bit of a minute and now we'll unfriend everyone
And then we'll redirect into Jimmy
a beautiful file
Floating unfriend and my friend
close
And then we keep cool
Oh my god
I love when you guys put information on your profile because it tells me everything about you. I'm like, oh
A deutschland. There's so many german. I'm sorry. We're gonna have to I need to like thank you for even tolerating my accent
If you're german
It doesn't make it like 10 times harder to understand me
I did I'm Thanos snapping the recent map
Do they deserve this? I don't know
View profile, I'll do the offline refunds because well, they're not at pc so
Report player. Yeah, it didn't carry me hard enough. Uh, get right
Shawna, you don't need to do it
complicate open up the friends list right click on the inkling most over
manage and then through your friends
Oh
Oh my gosh, you're so great. Oh my gosh
Oh, this is so much faster
Oh, wow, thank you reflin. Oh my god me opening up everyone's profiles just a pair of on you. I'm sorry you caught me in that
You caught me
You caught me. I'm stalking on main
You caught me on main. What can I say? Oh, wow, that's so much bad. Oh my god. I'm already like done
Uh, okay, and then someone's on counter strike
Yeah
Okay, and then as proof that everyone gone so I go friends I open I'm in game
nothing here
Then it says it's two but I think because I removed the refund it says two right now
But no refling to be said
I
Don't want to be
Icy got it from one moment
Where are the reflings gone? We're just um
Mommy reaching into our brain
Give that refling some but that she killed the refund. I'm wondering if you were felt for a stream grip or clan
Wait, does that wait?
If there's a clan can you come
Uh into the lobby
Via clan
She unfriended the foot. Yes
Stand up snap. They're dust. They're ashes and there's no like pending friend request either
No, I don't hate you
Via clan
No
No my only friend
My only friend
Okay, I am going to redirect into jimmy bisou before she goes offline
Uh, I'm going to thank you for the stream sniping and letting me ramble and goof off. I had no idea. Um
She said no, I don't
Play all day with you. Um, I am going to go like gremlin v go out for a job
So if anyone has a bird's eye view, you'll be able to see me outside buck-ass naked with a cat
And I am going to then nap and then if I successfully make my soup
I will take a picture
And you will get to see my soup and if I don't make it because I
End up napping far too long and I can't go get the ingredients. I will cry
Um, I wish I was omnipresent, right?
But thank you so so much for playing with me reeflands. I really enjoyed that. I I do have terrible news
I believe the string next stream snipe game will be overwatch. Unfortunately. I'm so sorry
I'm sorry. Okay. I want to play Juno. I didn't know she was out. I just want to give her
Well, I just want to try her. I just want to try her. Okay. I promise we're not turning into overwatch andy streamer
No, I just want to just want to try Juno for a couple hours play with the reef. Okay
Right. Thank you so so much. I will see you very soon. Please enjoy me as always
And how many teams did we have? We had one two three four five six seven eight nine ten eleven
one
two
three four five
Okay
Thank you very much. I see you tomorrow. No, you're talking in the background. You're ruining my outro
I'm just gonna have to kiss you a few more times. Did I join at the end? Unfortunately. Yes. I'm redirecting into
Jimmy. Fuck me. I started on the jet and then removed it and then added it back. Fuck you. Okay
Um, I see you later. See you tomorrow. We're gonna play tavern master. We're gonna open up our tavern
And I'll put a picture of my soup on screen for the menu
thick
Right. Enjoy Emmy. I see you later. Love you
Behave and look after yourself just like I should look after myself and then we'll look after each other
They'll self together and then each other at the same time. Okay. You know what? I mean that in contravern
Honestly, that's what I'll call it. Okay. I see you tomorrow. Bye
Oh, and you might have you're blowing ASMR uploaded as well soon TM, but not yet